the Texas National Guard has raised the
Gonzalez flag amid the fight with the
feds and Joe Biden and uh we're all
really excited for it but I don't know
that actually means anything but it is
the most fun news that we have it's been
a pretty slow news today the Gonzalez
flag for those that don't know is the
comment flag with the artillery on it
and the story is amazing we talked about
it a few nights ago considering the
artillery they were defending the single
K was relatively small but they were so
defensive of their right to keep it they
said come and take it they order to give
it up they said no we got a convoy
headed down to Texas and they are
concerns that this could cause
escalation James Lindsay has been saying
everybody should leave don't do this
don't give an opportunity for a false
flag but I think the reality is probably
a whole lot of nothing will happen but
we do have breaking news as it pertains
to the migrant crisis a video was just
published that appears to show military
in some fashion guarding illegal
immigrants at the Atlanta airport and
when a man a State Rep was caught
filming they shut him down and tried
taking his phone from him something
weird is going on so we'll talk about
that we got the big news James o'keef in
one of I got to say one of his best
exposes ever apparently he went on a
date with a guy and he went it was like
a Clark Kent thing he put on glasses and
then he starts asking this guy all these
stuff about what's going on in the White
House this is an executive
what is an employee in the executive
office of the White House in cyber
security who explains they want to
replace Kam Hera Kam Harris they don't
know how to do it they know Joe Biden's
in mental Decline and they're stuck
there's a lot more that came out in this
report but the best is probably when
James O'Keefe takes his glasses off and
says why are you having a meeting with
James O'Keefe if you're working in cyber
security and the guy's just like
dumbfounded I love it it's like you
didn't know that was James because he
was wearing glasses and the guy's like
oh yeah I've heard of you oh wow that's
an amazing story uh so we'll get into
all that stuff but before we do my
friends uhoh you know it we are shouting
out facts.com that's FS rap.com this is
Tom McDonald and bench airo song the
media is losing it they are on track for
for high rankings in the Billboard Hot
100 this is not a promo spot or a
sponsored spot I am doing this because I
am friends with these guys and I also
would love to get revenge on these woke
Industries and force our way in there if
anybody deserves to break through it's
Tom McDonald he teamed up with Ben
Shapiro they're generating a bunch of
Buzz and they are competing for the top
spot with Megan D Stallion and Nicki
Minaj and it looks like they may win
however Tom pointed out in a new video
just how the music industry cheats and
is fake and the corporate press is
trying to downplay what they're doing
the reason I tell you this this story is
more than just haha it's really funny
that Tom McDonald got a song with Ben
Shapiro we're going to break down how
the industry is fake well I want to talk
to you guys about how they trick people
into thinking these demonic music
artists who are telling your kids to be
degenerates they're not actually popular
they are lying it's a dirty trick and I
and what we're seeing now with Tom and
Ben is actually exposing that because so
many people are buying their song but
I'm going to save that first segment
because we do have an update Washington
Post wrote about it but uh facts fcs.com
also go to cast brew.com buy our coffee
if you want to support our work directly
Alex Stein's Prime Time grind two times
caffeine drink responsibly of course Cas
Brew it's the best C you'll ever had
everybody thinks Appalachia kns is the
best we're currently sold out of the
best but whole bean is still available
and you can join the cast Brew Coffee
Club if you want to get a discount on
multiple bags every single uh month and
also head over to
timcast.net you sign up what we will do
with your membership at 10 bucks a month
is we are going to invest in new shows
new culture documentaries we're working
on a show a Morning Show with multiple I
would say like mid 20s to early 40s
conservative women that uh it it was
asked of Me by a uh someone who works
here can we make a show that will be for
moms but sayane cuz you know the view is
like insane and so we want to do things
like this we want to have an impact on
culture in order to do it you got to
join up become a member at
timcast.net
media and uh according to DHS and TSA I
was an alleged domestic terrorist uh for
two years that's crazy dude that's fun
they were they were they were they were
stock you on these planes yep but you've
covered a lot of the Border crisis stuff
yes so this should be interesting
especially as we talk about what's going
on this this uh quote unquote militia
groups that are going down uh to the
border so uh should be fun thanks for
hanging out we got Hannah Clair brimo
hey I'm Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer
for scanner news that's cnr.com I'm
happy to be back this week uh Brett's
here as well yes hello guys I am Brett
dvic I'm the host of Pop Culture crisis
right here on YouTube me and Mary Morgan
do that show five days a week you should
tune in at 3M and watch and uh I'm
surge.com always a pleasure to have you
here Taylor as always and uh yeah I'm
excited for the show let's get to it Tim
here here's the big news of the day I
think it's fair to say there's probably
other news but let's I I'll be real very
slow news day that's true but this was
the most fun story Texas National Guard
flies come and take it flag as border
tensions grow this is it take a look at
this do you guys know what the Gonzalez
flag is they have this picture what I
love about it is the flag shows it's
kind of hard to see on the screen SC it
shows artillery a single star and it
says come and take it and it was
basically uh you know in Texas these
guys had a cannon and there was some you
know military officer I think it was
Mexican and he was like you are going to
surrender that Cannon to me and they
made that flag and said come and take it
and it's just this little artillery is
not very big and it's just one but this
symbol that was made that day is it's
powerful and right now there's concerns
that Joe Biden will make moves to
federalize the nation guard Abbott says
nationalizing Texas National Guard would
be a severe Biden political blunder but
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen I I think a lot of people uh the
smart move on Biden's part is to slow
down and back off and let things simmer
down otherwise if he makes a move it can
escalate quickly out of his control but
of course because that happens everybody
seems to think nothing will happen I
don't know that that's the case
considering all the other news that
we've been seeing and the fact that even
with Texas National Guard putting up the
razor wire this has not stopped the bill
that's being proposed where Joe Biden's
like I've done everything I can you got
to give me the power the bill they're
proposing would give Joe
Biden 5,000 criminal aliens I'm not
talking about migrants or ases or
whatever 5,000 criminal aliens every day
would be allowed to cross that's the
deal Joe Biden basically I got I got to
give it to him he's a mass he must have
read the art of the deal read some
Donald Trump the big ask Joe Biden
allows wave after wave of criminal
migrant to come in this country and then
says how about we stop it at 5,000 and
that's a deal brutal I I don't know
where this goes Texas Texas National
Guard I know you've been down there
quite a bit and you've seen some of this
so I'm curious your thoughts Taylor yeah
well I mean just in Shelby Park in an
Eagle pass in specific I mean it is
cleaned up it is day and night
difference I mean was down there I would
say at the beginning of January and I
mean they went I did a little tour with
National Guard they were nice enough to
let me in and actually go and see the
razor wire and you know they kind of
gave me the ends of how many Crossings
had actually been stopped on average
they were averaging anywhere when I was
down there it was six to four migrants a
day compared to you know I was there the
month prior no 6 to four that's it wait
with with National Guard in Shelby Park
in one of the regions in the Del Rio
sector that used to be one of the most
popular and I mean they were shattering
records every single month per day yeah
well in the month before that if you
guys saw the kind of makeup apprehension
site where you had thousands I mean
filling in every single 10 minutes as
one line is cleared another line fills
that's how much of a difference that it
has made in that one sector so now
you're seeing rises in the Arizona
sectors and migrants are making their
way over there or 15 miles you know
Upland and now they're Crossing in that
area but it's still not nearly as much
so it is working this is the challenge
of separate states sovereign states the
Biden Administration as a federal agency
just wants to bring in criminal criminal
aliens so when Texas says we're going to
push back all the Biden Administration
has to do is or I shouldn't say the bid
Administration but whoever is
communicating with the cartels to let
them know how to operate send them send
them to Arizona I'm sure they got CBP
down there that's willing to facilitate
the the human Smugglers operations and
if anybody who lives there tries to
defend their property we we'll put them
in prison that seems to be the case and
this wasn't the case under uh dug duy
Who had who was really supportive of
Abbott he also bust people out of state
uh it's apparent to me how obvious the
changes in our state leadership are to
people in other countries right we have
we know people pay attention to the
America's um presidential elections but
I think the turnover from a republican
Governor to a Democratic governor
immediately opened up Arizona in a way
that became apparent to the
International Community that's looking
to perforate the Border yeah well in
Arizona is an absolute mess right now if
you look at like Ali Bradley or any of
the reporters of the news nation that
are down there they done a really good
job at covering it and now you're seeing
numbers spike in that area once again
while the Del Rio sector is drastically
dropping and you know there's a big
difference between those two sectors the
kinds of migrants that you get through
you get a lot of Chinese National coming
through in the Arizona sectors they're
treated a lot differently in tapachula
which is kind of the conglomeration uh
grounds in Mexico where you know they're
kind of sent up I mean they have
full-blown hotels and you know routes
and guides for these Chinese people
because they have more money so then
they're guided into over in you know the
Tijana area and they're treated you know
with respect they don't really have to
go through the cartels but the
Venezuelans the Hondurans those types
that you're seeing come through Eagle
Pass consistently you know they're often
times being traded from Cartel to cartel
every single step of the away did when
you were down there before the National
Guard shut everything down right yep and
then afterwards as well so explain
explain like just what it looks like
when cbp's in charge when CBP is in
charge it's an absolute mess I mean it
is migrants coming in at all times of
the day all times of the night most of
the biggest influxes you see is anywhere
between like 5: to 9:00 a.m. in the
morning that's really when you see them
get hit hard with the big Caravans that
cross over you'll have an NGO last time
I was in Mexico I like to report from
the Mexico side cuz I feel that's kind
of where the story actually is you can
follow the Caravans over and the NOS
they're located in Mexico they'll have
you know two double wide basically barn
doors that they have anywhere between a
few hundred to a thousand migrants in
that are ready to go that morning and
then they'll walk them down to the river
the coyote will if they have one and
then they'll cross them into the real gr
and then they'll be put in that
makeshift apprehension site at least
that's how it wasal aliens yes you
accidentally said migrant yeah yeah I
have tremendous respect for migrants who
come to the United States believe in the
American dream apply at the appropriate
border crossing and say thank you for
everything you've you've you've every
opportunity you've afforded me I hope
that the paperwork moves through and I
can come to your country well none of
them are actually going through the
checkpoints and that's for a reason well
no no no migrants are criminal aliens
are not yep and and that's the legal
term I I think uh you know uh shout out
James Lindsay he had this post where he
said do not use the leftist language it
is a political agenda so when we are
specifically referring to individuals
who are committing crimes against the
United States and against Texas and
they're being assisted by the Biden
Administration to which the Texas
governor has called out the Biden ad
Administration for doing those are the
criminal criminal aliens and I just I
would not want to bch the good name of
migrants because I like migrants I I
like the people who respect this country
it doesn't mean they get to come in
doesn't mean they get to move here but
sometimes they do and through the
appropriate means that's beneficial to
the economy beneficial to the
communities what's going on with the
with Southern border and CBP and Biden
is is the is the antithesis it is
destructive is chaos the crazy thing to
me is as you described like these ngos
bringing these big Caravans what's their
goal just sewing chaos and hurting these
people basically every single step of
the way I mean they get paid every
single step of the way a lot of the NOS
that operate in Mexico are also
operating in America so or they're
working together in some fashion or some
capacity so you'll have them cross and
then immediately after they're done
being processed the NGO will step in
which you know when Eagle Pass and all
these other border towns they quite
literally have buildings there and then
they start facilitating these migrants
and then uh you know the one in San
Antonio that I was at last month or at
the beginning of January where San
Antonio PD was essentially running
private security facilitating the human
smuggling of these illegals they quite
literally put them in this area for an x
amount of time and then they say Hey you
know if you can afford your own ticket
or they kind of phrase it in a little
more aggressive manner they try and get
these illegals to buy their own tickets
and then if they aren't willing to buy
their own tickets after a certain amount
of time or they can't afford it they'll
end up saying okay we can pay half and
then they still can't afford it they end
up paying the full thing who's pay who's
paying it the NGS wow I mean they should
be they should be uh there should be
some kind of criminal uh uh
investigation charges against the
organizations for facilitating illegal
immigration I mean it's laughable CBP
the only reason the cartels and the
Smugglers are able to to operate is
because CBP was like we got you MH
absolutely well and that's the same
thing with the you know San Antonio PD
running security for this facility they
are essentially taking cartel money
because cartels will pay these NOS
because they're doing their dirty work
and their groundwork for them and then
it's washed through San Antonio the city
of San Antonio essentially and then
given to these officers at a higher rate
than they're already being paid which
San Antonio PD they're already getting
paid good money but they're still
willing to go and do this in uniform and
actually guard these migrant facilities
and essentially threaten you with arrest
if you keep asking them questions as
they did with me feels like there is a
boa constrictor on the neck of this
country slowly just squeezing and
squeezing and uh man the challenge is
discipline I feel like the best thing we
can do is hope that by voting for Donald
Trump he gets in and starts to reverse
course and there's no guarantees that
happens but that is the best path
forward we have right now and that being
said Greg Abbott seems to have done a
lot to to Abate this but now now we need
Arizona and New Mexico to do the same
New Mexico won't New Mexico will always
just say we're an Open Door they're
Democrat run they're trying to ban guns
they doing a whole bunch of crazy stuff
yeah New Mexico Arizona California
they're not going to do anything and
they think that's one of the reasons um
Abbott taking such a strong stance was a
rallying cry we saw so many what over 25
States said we're with you we're going
to support you and they aren't all
necessarily directly attached to the
Border but they feel the burdens of
illegal immigration as well we know that
especially the bid Administration has
moved people who come illegally
throughout the country and this becomes
a nationwide problem I think for a long
time it was marketed as well it's just
Texas's problem it's just in the Border
communities and you know that
frustration really lit a fuse and I mean
operation loans Abbott's initiative to
to close the border and to add more
State um Power behind efforts to
restrict legal immigration has been
going on since 2021 I mean he launched
it alongside the Biden Administration
and they're really seeing this come to a
head after four years well and you see a
lot of those states that are actually
signing on or actually receiving an
influx of illegal migrants too or I
should say criminal aliens as Tim States
it well that's that's the illegal term
of it and I mean even Utah I remember
when I was flying back from my San
Antonio and last Eagle Pass trip I'm
looking at these illegal
uh pass I mean these basically these
boarding passes that are makeshift and
they're completely different most of the
time than most other boarding passes and
I'm looking through some and I look at
my gate and I see six right there and I
was like there's no way they're coming
to Utah out of all places and lo and
behold they're coming to Utah they're in
Chicago they're being flown on private
jets I mean it's just absolutely nuts to
think you out there listen hardworking
American you lived your whole life you
followed the rules you didn't break any
laws you got a job you went to school
you got married you had kids and you see
on Instagram and you see in the news
these people getting to fly on these
private jets and you think you know what
did I have to do differently in my life
to be able to fly in a private jet
apparently you need to be born in a
third world country and then illegally
enter the United States because they're
putting these people on large private
jets flying them through private jet
terminals to big cities giving them
hotel rooms cell phones and debit cards
with thousands of dollars in cash well
and they get expedited security too so
that's a fun part of it all well that's
a that's that's another big story we
have let's take a look at this from uh
Daily Caller check check this one out
exclusive video appears to show migrants
tucked away in Hidden room under
military guard at major US airport we
actually have the video here from Daily
Caller I don't know if if everyone it's
it's really I don't even know if you can
see it because the way they needed to
rotate this why did the Daily Caller
rotate the video they were busy it was
breaking so in this video uh I'm going
to play I'm going to lowerer the volume
there's a man it's uh it's up here at
the top you can see a guy in some kind
of military uh uniform I don't know if
he's National Guard or if he's army or
or what he might
be but uh it's hard to see because they
also put their their watermark over it
yeah so I I I don't I don't I don't know
how to show it to you any better those
that are watching but apparently this
was filmed by a state senator let me uh
uh get the details on on on this state
senator Colton Moore a republican Vice
chairman of the Georgia Freedom caucus
took the video apparently when he tried
to film directly this guy in uniform
went up to him and told him he was done
shut him down try to take his phone from
him so that would indicate I know
they're trying to be careful here saying
appears to show migrants under military
guard fair point because we don't know
if this guy's actually in the we don't
know who this guy is but I think I think
you can say it does show it now the
question is who is this guy was he given
direct orders to protect illegal
immigrants criminal aliens or is he
acting of his own valtion is he working
private we don't know what's going on
but this is just one grain of sand in
the if you knew actually how bad things
were like look for years we've known the
bid Administration was smuggling
children criminal illegal I should say
for the kids they're brought here by
their parents I guess Criminal Alien
applies I'm not entirely sure but
undocumented children bought brought
here by cartels Smugglers and their
parents are then put on planes by the
body Administration and FL to Tennessee
to New York to other other cities and
states in the middle of the night the
the it's it's it's it's insane to me
that the B Administration has been doing
this for years do you know what airport
this is in do they say so it's an
Atlanta airport II I think is it yeah
Atlanta's heartsfield Jackson looks like
I need to take a visit to Atlanta I mean
Kudos are the senator for filming this
but he should have walked up to the
National Guard or whoever it was and
said what are you doing here why are you
guarding this what in what capacity are
you working if he was then who would
have been funding him NOS well why is he
wearing his uniform you would not be you
would be against policy right to wear
uniform at least with the police
departments they have to get approval
through the city and through their
police chief I'm not sure how it works
in the military it's got to be National
Guard yeah it doesn't seem right though
because of posi katus Armed Forces can't
be used for uh domestic law enforcement
unless there are some exceptions I think
the Insurrection Act is one so I'm
assuming it's a national Guardsman in in
Georgia who's been sent for some reason
but I got to tell you like I'm going to
say this if this is true these are
criminal aliens this state senator had a
whistleblower came to him and told him
this was going on if that is a room of
criminal aliens being trafficked being
smuggled and that Guardsman is
protecting them I want to see him in
prison oh absolutely lock them up well
that's that's thing is people are so
lenient with everybody that's doing this
I mean like I think the San Antonio PD
Officers that I confronted I think they
should be in prison 100% why are you in
an official capacity or unofficial
capacity in your uni forms you using
your service weapons using your cars
allowed to facilitate human trafficking
and smuggling into America when that's
illegal and it's something you should
actually be investigating it's insane it
makes absolutely no sense in my mind and
this isn't the worst of it it's it's
funny that you know this video comes out
this is a a Daily Caller exclusive this
is uh Jenny tear and it's just like I I
think we can all surmise it's a it's
much worse than we realize you know
James o' ke for instance exposes these
buses that are driving Criminal aliens
there is a massive human smuggling
Network to the tune of billions of
dollars that's been full swing over the
past couple of years under Joe Biden and
Joe Biden's in on it I got a question is
his family getting Kickbacks probably I
mean there you can't trust anything the
Biden family does in my personal opinion
part of this is anything any nothing he
he could rescue puppies and be like what
was I honestly would think it was stage
because there's no way that man can move
fast enough to rescue a puppy but the
thing is the illegal immigration under
Biden has increased by basically a
million people every year cumulatively
at over 6 million people so of course
this system is starting to burst at the
seams I mean if you look at the
Massachusetts at Logan Airport in Boston
there are migrants there are videos of
migrants just sleeping on the floor
there's nowhere for them to go for years
Massachusetts has been saying I mean at
least for the last six months I should
say Massachusetts has been warning we're
at capacity we don't have any place to
put anyone we need to do something and
there're sort of no answer because the
federal government government has
refused to uh enforce immigration law
refus used to uh Ally itself with the
states that are acting to defend
themselves and now we're all paying the
consequences I mean it is not obviously
I think if you entered this country
illegally you were obviously a criminal
you doing something wrong but I can
understand that they are also suffering
in the conditions that they are being
housed no one wants to sleep on the
floor at an airport indefinitely like no
one benefits from this system except for
Joe Biden and Democrats who
theoretically could maybe stash people
in States and tip the census uh even
then they're not just being stashed
airports either I mean we see it in
Chicago O'Hare Airport too there's a
whole section of tents that are now
being marked off to Media after Ben
buram went down there and basically
exposed what was going on to the extent
that it was going on and they have
little privacy flyers on it do not enter
you know it's essentially like they're
living there but on top of that a lot of
the times when I talk to these illegals
in the airport they have no idea where
they're going and then their pickup I I
I asked to see what their WhatsApp is
because that's where they do all the
facilitation with the Nos and almost
every single time they're heading to a
local community Community Center that
has basically been I don't know if it's
rented out or what's going on but
they're basically all being
conglomerated and put in recck centers
for who knows yeah so they're either
sleeping on the rec center floor or
they're sleeping in the airport
somewhere or they're just disappearing
so and even if it's not Kickbacks per se
everyone knows right now that bringing
in that demographic is voting block
material in future elections because the
elections aren't safe either a lot of
the time yeah young military age men so
great no I think all of this is is it's
interesting to me to see how much the
conversation around uh the border and
immigration have Shi has shifted over
the last basically 20 years right I mean
there were times when this wasn't a
subject that conservatives would touch
at all and now you know maybe not super
effectively but at least they are
willing to say we're not doing anything
until the border is a top priority and I
think that's the best thing they can do
for their constituents any elected
Republican should know that this isn't
just something that we do to not
encourage people to inder themselves by
Crossing ille illegally this country but
it's to say I prioritize the people who
put me in office I want you guys to feel
safe and feel as though the resources
that your tax dollars are supposed to
support go to you it is weird how like
even like during the Obama
Administration illegal border crossing
was something that was least they paid
lip service to it right in some way
shape or form and that kind of
disappeared when Trump got elected and
it became such a contentious issue kids
in cages things like that and it's kind
of become well I feel like under Obama
the The Narrative was we deser people
need help and it's Our obligation as
this powerful wealthy Nation to you know
help them whatever else but they talked
about the Border fence and like it was
at least paid lip service well Obama
actually built a portion of the wall as
well a lot of people don't understand
that that part of that wall actually was
built in the Obama Administration also
the cages were built in the Obama
administ that's something people don't
know well no the I think they changed
the name they only became cages when
Trump got elected I think that they were
migrant holding facilities until then
and then they became cages
fac well the biggest difference between
it's all about who's in who's in office
and who knows how to actually use their
power and who controls the media at this
point so when Democrats are in office
it's always a humanitarian issue and we
need to save these people We're a nation
with the money to save these people and
to give them the life that they need and
deserve allegedly and then when Trump's
in office or somebody in the GOP is in
office then oh it becomes an issue of we
are essentially attacking these people
and denying them their basic human
rights to illegally cross into our
country so someone super chated this is
um what do it say Latin 342 that the guy
in the video is wearing a brown round
the Hat mhm and that uh National Guard
doesn't don't have that it's a drill
sergeant hat so it's got to be Federal I
don't know where in the video you can
see that it does look for a brief small
portion there may be a brim off the back
of his head I don't know if you can tell
if that is a full I mean for all we know
he's wearing a backwards baseball cap I
doubt it I had a guy in uniform we be
wearing that but uh that would be
interesting uh nonetheless don't know
for sure well the senator that is
recording this video is watching right
now send me the details and I'll be
there in a few days to ask questions cuz
or he can just send you the details and
say yes the guy was wearing a brown
round and described the patch on his arm
and and and we can figure out if this
guy's working for the federal government
it may be it may be look I mean I mean
that would be a huge Scandal I'd imagine
if us armed forces ferally were
facilitating this
because that's I mean I that might be
into the area of a military coup
outright well especially with what you
have going down in Shelby pass right now
you know they're they're allowed to stop
it but they're actually not allowed to
stop it according to the Biden
Administration but then on one side if
this actually is somebody in the army or
the National Guard then they're actively
facilitating it while trying to
nationalize the National Guard in Texas
so you have a huge uh you know budding
of heads issue right there I mean this
is this is if that is federal Armed
Forces I don't know what you'd call this
because you know I've described what Joe
Biden's been doing as a seditious
conspir iracy MH treason typically
refers to or more likely refer to acts
of war and supporting enemies treason
being a traitor right what does it mean
to be a traitor you're helping the enemy
okay so let's say you know Taylor and
Hannah Clair are fighting over a slice
of uh uh cake and then I'm like you know
I bought I'm I'm here to defend you it's
your cake and then I go behind your back
and go I'm a traitor I betrayed you
right that's treason sedition would just
be like trying to destroy this country
and it seems like that's what is going
on I love that example yes but you but I
have to imagine perhaps it's treason I
mean if they're working with cartels it
is treason then because now they're
aiding and abetting an enemy that we are
in active conflict with that's nuts man
I don't I don't know what to say and the
Biden Administration no matter what
happens will say you guys are crazy this
has always been the way things are done
or you didn't see it right this is this
is a right-wing conspiracy and the media
will run cover for them I mean that's
why I lose a lot of faith whenever we
cover any story like this when you hear
any stuff like this I just don't see it
reaching the average American because
everyone's so in their Echo Chambers
anyways the people who will get this
media the ones who are s like searching
it out whether they're using alt media
like this or they watch Fox or o or
anything like this they already agree
with you and the people that you would
like to reach and hopefully show that
this is happening they're not going to
be watching any media that actually
catches on to this but it's still you
know the information must spread and it
it is fascinating to hear how the
migrant crisis has really shifted a lot
of people in this country towards the
right and I think it has been a slow
boil issue I think concern about the
Border has increased over the last 10 I
mean even under Trump right when Trump
was saying I want to build the wall
there were people who were excited about
that because they already felt the
burdens of immigration on their
Community especially legal immigration
and so the idea that under Biden it got
worse on top of everything else that
Biden has done I I don't know that there
is enough spin out there I think it has
really punctured through uh mainstream
narrative I think even people who are
not political start to say yeah why why
are we letting this happen Ian just my
the the San Antonio video that I filmed
earlier this month it breached over I
think 4.5 million just on Twitter off of
tenet's page and not including the
repost on Instagram on Twitter I mean on
multiple different I mean it went viral
on Facebook as well and on multiple
YouTube channels so you're still
breaking into the apparatus of you know
normies so to call and which that's a
good thing which I think if any issue is
going to change people's Minds on what's
going on in the country it's going to be
this issue CU you can go into any
airport I always encourage people to do
this pretty much any airport in the
country look around from Manila or clear
envelopes you're going to see illegal
immigrants on your flight or on flights
around you and wandering throughout the
airport let's jump to the story from NBC
News some supporters of a far-right
convoy headed to the Texas border are
calling for civil war we love NBC news
they are crack pot far- leftists but uh
sure a group that referred to itself as
Gods Army said it was planning three
peaceful assemblies on Saturday the
Convoy is attracted only a small number
so far well like 12 people I think they
say it's a trucker Convoy of
self-described Patriots headed toward
the US border with Mexico they've
expressed violent rhetoric before ah you
see but they don't give examples they
don't give examples they never it's fine
it's like when they say that the they're
they have specific tweets that are bad
and they never actually include the
Tweets in the article do not this is why
I agree with James Lindsay James James
Lindsay said do not go down there oh
yeah I agree I think
you go to Texas stay from the border let
Greg Abbott do his job we've already
learned today from a field reporter
who's actually been there that what Greg
Abbott has set up has massively worked
you were saying before it's it's bedum
and then once the National Guard comes
in now it's four to six like which is an
insane contrast single digits from
10,000 I think was 10,000 the whole
border though or was so it's in certain
diff they break it up into sectors uh
when I was down there they were breaking
records every single month so you had
thousands coming through it wasn't like
10,000 all at once you never see any
Crossings like that but you do see
thousands per day sometimes and as soon
as the National Guard of Texas takes
over it has mostly solved the problem if
people show up and get in the way you're
getting in the way of the guys winning
it's like no don't do that don't do that
especially because it looks like NBC is
trying to Prime normies to expect
violence and calls for civil war so do
not give them an opportunity to false
flag and I'll most likely be down there
covering whatever this turns into uh but
I don't really see it going very far I
mean I saw a Fox News hit the other day
where they said 700,000 Vehicles were on
their way which I don't know where they
came up with that number you know I've
been in contact people in the Convoy it
isn't happening that's not how big they
are yeah you have a few thousand people
heading down but there's also three
different end points so they're going to
be split up between three different
endpoints in different sectors of the
border so I'm not expecting you know a
huge crowd there but articles like like
this is it's basically just priming
people and prepping people for what
would be a false flag like what are you
possibly going to do going down to the
border to actually help National Guard
or to help the good guys win in this it
was very different than the tur Convoy
where they're basically locking down all
around Canadian Parliament and saying
we're going to make your life so
difficult because you have made our life
so difficult I know I don't really see
the same symbolic thing I understand
wanting to show your support obviously
wanting to do something I I I like the
idea of called action but ultimately
anyone I know who knows about this has
started being like feds feds everywhere
yep and and a lot of people think it's
going to be j6 all over again I feel
like that about anything where there's
any amount of protest now right because
it's not a matter of who goes it's a
matter of who controls the media
narrative around what happens right you
know but I don't think the media media
narrative matters as much as people
think I I I I I'm well beyond this like
we just saw digital media implode over
the past few weeks and it's been in
freef Fall for the past couple years one
of the worst days ever they got to call
like bloody Thursday or something how
many layoffs there were this week yeah
Taylor Loren's video of her complaining
about all of it I mean they're laying
people off during election season you
know election writers as well which is
insane but I have a problem with you
know people not attending like I
understand protests I understand the
point of them obviously they're not
hyper effective especially after January
6 but everybody has essentially been
neutered after January 6 and I was there
on January 6 so I understand the Ramic
I'm not saying don't protest don't
organize don't get together don't have
assemblies I'm saying
don't go up against CBP on federal
jurisdiction during a conflict
especially when border patrol has
essentially sided with the National
Guard in this situation I think the
protest was planned before the Shelby
Park stuff happened but now that this is
actually going on it does lead to
potential problems or conflict and I
don't
care in Arizona have you been at the
Arizona border a few times not not as
much as CBP facilitating illegal
immigration everywhere everywhere so
when they come out and they're like no
you know we agree with Texas and then
they they go now keep the human
smuggling running in Arizona I'm like I
don't care that you you get no free
passes yeah they've realized they've
lost in Texas but they still got New
Mexico they got Arizona they got
California so they're they're probably
looking at it like Hey we're a bunch of
human Smugglers Texas is going up
against us if we go to war with them it
could screw the whole operation up let's
call it a loss and then shift all the
cartel operations to these states so we
can keep getting our Kickbacks or
whatever it is they're doing on the it
is is they haven't even lost in Texas at
this point just in the Shelby Park and
Eagle Path sector which is where most
migrants I mean illegal migrants do come
through because 15 miles upwards you're
still having you know illegal immigrants
cross this area so it's still happening
you're just not seeing these massive
groups but you are still allowing
they're still allowing people to be
processed and there are rumors that you
know any immigrants that are being you
know basically detained by National
Guard or essentially being handed off to
CBP there are some videos out there so
it could still just be you know it could
just be for looks which would be a shame
but I don't think it is that in this
case um but they need to do this for all
of Texas the entirety of the Texas
border if they're actually serious about
stopping illegal immigration completely
I think when we
see the actions of a lot of people on
the right I shouldn't I shouldn't say
the right you know but there are people
who claim to be anti-establishment
who in two seconds jumped ship and went
full full on establishment at moment's
notice and I wonder what would happen if
a civil war actually broke out and I
genuinely believe if in Texas something
kicked off between the feds first people
should understand this when we had Eric
Prince on the culture War show shout out
tenant media Friday mornings 10 a.m. he
said I asked him like do you do you see
in the United States similar things to
these countries you've been in and he
said the one thing I can tell you is
that everybody I know who's been in
these countries they said it happened
overnight one day you went to bed
everything was fine you woke up the
internet's out electricity is out you
have no idea what's going on and that's
true if you're are in the conflict
region what is also true is that most
places it's the it'll be it'll it'll be
it'll be nothing what'll happen you're
in New York right you'll go down to your
Bodega to get a uh I don't know maybe
you want to get a turkey with American
cheese on a Kaiser oh man is that what
they eat out there I I used to so I
would I would get whenever I would go to
the bodegas yeah I'd be like turkey
white American yellow American Mayo
Kaiser heat up so good I love me my
bodegas but you're going to be there
you're going to see the clerk who you
know your neighbor and you're going to
be like and he's going to be like 13
more dead down at Eagle Pass the
fighting's getting crazy down there and
you'll go wow that's crazy anyway uh uh
you see the parade at the park we're
going to go check it out you're going to
be there later all right see you there
when I was in uh I went to Ukraine in
2016 and or 2017 and this is ongoing
fighting happening in the donbass region
at the time but it was limited
skirmishes nobody in Kiev had said
anything like it's whatever and it was
funny because when if when the fighting
first kicked off people were saying
Civil War but then Donald Trump becomes
president the fighting starts simmering
down and I go there my friends like we
don't say Civil War it's just
separatists fighting and I'm like
fascinating and it was completely out of
sight out of mind for everybody there
went to a sushi restaurant went to a uh
I don't know what you to call it like
fast casual with buffet style and got
cabbage and beef it was delicious had
fun well I think the US is a very unique
place in the aspect of it's probably
going to happen just like you're saying
it's happening is you know you'll have
different regions of the us that aren't
affected by it at all it's just news to
them and a lot of people they won't even
hear about the news at all they won't
even understand that anything is going
on and then finally you will have
something crack that does affect the
rest of the country but the way that the
US is set up and the way that our
economy and everything else is set up in
this country is it's not just going to I
don't think it's just going to be an
overnight thing blackout completely you
know all across the United States and it
very well could be Eric Prince's a
genius I mean he knows his stuff for
sure but the way that we're set up here
in the US is very unique compared to all
these other regions that experience
massive attacks like this if you're in
these border regions where fighting
breaks out yeah you're you're going to
wake up with electricity yep I mean the
the federal government's going to be
like we need to cut off their energy we
need to cut off their Communications
you're going to wake up and have no
internet your phone's not going to work
and there's going to be a military
Insurrection act declared there will be
either Texas or federal military
securing the area saying everything's
under control go back inside your house
and you're not going to know who's who
uh imagine you're in Texas near Shelby
Park Eagle Pass you're in the city or
whatever and a and an APC pulls up and
guys military uniforms jump out the
average person can't tell the difference
between National Guard and and and Army
and this guy just they they pull up they
Park the trucks out they're standing
guard you get out of your house there
something going on like a everything's
cool man uh you know name's Jim we're
just doing security because there's been
some conflict stuff going on but you got
nothing to worry about have a nice day
which who is it which faction is you
won't even know it's like that uh the
trailer for civil war yeah what kind of
American are you they don't know who he
is well the most unrealistic thing about
that is a Texas California Alliance that
no that's totally realistic the the
movie has Texas and California as their
own countries not as two countries
working to it is not one country with
two states Texas and California both
wanting Independence would align
militaristically to defend their
sovereignty they wouldn't be operating
under the same governance so that makes
it makes a lot of sense they were flying
like one flag though two stars okay yeah
but there's like a NATO flag yeah here
here's here's here's my point when I was
saying earlier
you've got Florida a lot of prominent
conservative voices in
Florida if Civil War or some kind of hot
separatist action or whatever breaks out
in Texas not saying it will who knows I
guarantee you will get these right-wing
uh
personalities immediately saying I'm on
the side of Joe
Biden and I'm not talking about right
now it's easy to be like Texas is in the
right but but if it comes to the point
where Texas is in active full full-on
bullets flying conflict and federal
agents are returning fire and then the
Insurrection Act is declared and then
Joe Biden declar he says Insurrection
Texas blah blah blah it's going to be
real interesting because the question
will be will Florida say this is an
overreach an abuse of power by the
federal government this is an in
escalation what will state say and more
importantly for those content creators
with a national audience and National
ties
Which side will they find themselves on
that's when you really put people to the
test the question is who do you think's
going to win for some people it's who do
they want to win so there will be some
media personalities and I
think the higher the higher I I don't
want to name anybody and put anybody on
the spot but there are some prominent
personalities that are streaming on you
know you YouTube and Rumble that I fully
imagine would be absolutely on the moral
position whether it is morally right or
wrong whatever anyone does they're going
to they're going to stick to their guns
there's a handful of people I would
imagine outright would just be like hey
guys I'm with Joe Biden on this one
it'll be interesting to see well the
people that don't have convictions and
can hold themselves to their morals
they're going to be the side you know
siding with the federal government
essentially siding with the big man and
that's really all that it comes down to
you side with the side that's in
Rebellion or he's in States the
Insurrection act you are now putting a
Target on yourself and not a lot of
people especially commentators are
actually willing to go that far they
don't want documents like that I'll give
you an example CLA Leman do you remember
her off the top of my head I don't think
whatever happened to that lady do you
guys remember CLA Leman no she was uh
intellectual dark web she runs quillette
I believe she probably still does she
was of the uh you know the intellectual
dark Webb people were like post- liberal
academics thinkers and and media
personalities that had been challenging
woke Orthodoxy and the establishment
narratives and right and so she's
running quette and quette was his
publication that was like basically
disaffected liberal classically Liber
classically liberal and then Co happened
and Australia set up actual internment
camps were forcefully relocating
indigenous people I remember that story
and she came out in full defense of it
yeah why she's living under the boot of
an authoritarian regime and so she's
thinking to herself I will go to prison
and be locked up in a camp if I speak
out against them so the only thing I can
do is be on their side and I think you
could see the cognitive disson and the
shattering of her mind because she knew
if I start calling out Howard Springs we
have that t-shirt like come vacation
Howard Springs there were there's one
story where three indigenous kids in a
small community in the middle of nowhere
they came took them under suspicion of
covid contact brought them to an
internment camp and locked them up and
said you can't leave they threw like
blankets over the razor wire jumped the
fence and escaped and they were hunted
down they were trying to arrest them I'm
like yeah totally voluntary covid you
know camp and she's like they're not
concentration camps I'm like well
they're literally driving up in Vans
taking indigenous people and people from
their homes bringing them to camps and
locking them up they're concentrating
them now okay fine Fair Point you you
you think the illusion to World War II
is too strong in tournament camps yeah
but she this this is my point this going
to be a lot of people who will flip on a
dime and they would have been the most
Libertarian people in the world but the
moment they realize hey look man I live
in DC I I live I live just north of DC
in Maryland I'm going to get arrested in
two seconds if I speak up it's going to
be interesting to see who does that Co
proved that as well a lot how many
people kind of fell under the regime as
soon as things started getting called
that way like you said she immediately
Falls in line because of the way things
are going and I think that would
continue I think it's fair to point out
too don't not everybody agrees on
everything okay here we are right now
saying to the people who are going down
Texas we do not want violence we need
Trump to win in the event something
actually kicked off hot I am going to
maintain that position to hope for
stability so that Donald Trump can still
take the presidency that being said I
don't know and I'm not going to say
anything as to what happens here other
than we don't want it to happen you do
not want Civil War I don't think the
average American gets it to be fair I
think the average person who watches a
show like this gets it a little bit
better and all of the military veterans
get it
100% it is your the world you knew is
gone you will continue shopping and
eating food and cooking but man you ever
see a rabbit eating grass outside
just a little ball of stress the whole
time you never know when you're about to
get snatched up by some bird of prey or
some owl or who knows what and so you're
hiding all day every day it is not going
to be fun you know you never know when
someone's for no reason gonna gon to
attack you and maybe even accidentally
it's just not going to be it's not going
to be as chill and comfortable is this
the issue Trump runs on immigration
immigration and economy AB he already is
he's already run that's how 2016 they're
saying like what is his biggest loss
right now is female voters right like
does the does the vote on migrant crisis
affect does that really push the female
voters in his demograph like I think
immigration is becoming a very unifying
issue for conservative or even moderate
people because the effects are so
far-reaching and they can see them all
the time uh the thing is with the Convoy
to the Border there are people who want
to be involved they want to be on the
ground whatever
else I would say that Abbott has been
preparing to be in this position for a
long time and it's better to let him
work and to be supportive in a different
way H it's the same thing with Trump I
mean people will criticize Trump saying
he didn't do enough when he was in
office to achieve you know whatever with
with immigration but we because he was
the president we have advanced this
conversation and it's become even more
mainstream under a Democratic president
they couldn't deny what was going on
here's a story from the New York Post
Costco emergency food kits spark wild
con conspiracy theory by doomsday
prepper it's not just a Doomsday prepper
there are many and you don't I think
doomsday prepper is is where they're
trying to go you that language is
intenal preer prepper is fine not
everybody who's prepping is prepping for
the Doomsday they're prepping because
sometimes it rains and when flood waters
come in you need food but let me just
start by say buys toilet paper when Co
hits let me just say you guys have seen
the show Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
what a fun show man I remember back in
the Heyday of Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire watching was like an ABC you
know how old was I like 10 years old and
they have a Lifeline where you can ask
the audience and it only really works
with like the earlier questions that are
kind of easy you know it would be like
which you know which country is the
first country to do whatever and then
like I don't know I'm G to ask the
audience and then it shows like most
people said a wisdom of the crowd it's
called what we're seeing with Costco is
really interesting they've released
these emergency meals you can buy and uh
We've we've also pitched our you know
one of our sponsors safeand ready
meals.com
now Costco is selling these these
readywise buckets you can buy that
contain is what do they say 132 pasta
meals for
$63.99 these are these are these are
price saving as it were why is Costo
doing this the conspiracy theory is
something bad is about to happen maybe
it's World War III maybe it's Civil War
I think I can up the ante on you it is
not just that there is a deep State plot
like the the the government knows
something's going to happen and they
want people to buy the stuff to be ready
without triggering alarm maybe it could
be worse in a different way
Costco just follows
demand Costco is not being told to do
this so that they can prepare the
population for World War I they're doing
it because the population believes World
War III is about to happen and the
wisdom of the crowd is we need to stock
up on emergency meals right now and gold
cuz they're selling gold because it's
about to get bad Costco just simply
reacts to the demand yes I think that's
entirely true because the thing is there
are a lot of really good videos about
Costco's business model they keep fewer
items on the shelves than an average
grocery store but the things that are
there they only keep if they're selling
and so they will occasionally test items
you'll see things that come for a little
while and go but if they think that this
is something people are going to buy
it's a big decision because they only
keep a limited number of items it's
interesting to me that Costco has said
people want this item we're going to
keep we're going to bring it in and
we're going to see how long we can sell
it for we so we did uh we we we I
periodically do pitches for uh one of
our sponsors safeand ready meals.com and
when we do it's only when there's like a
big event that scares people and it's
not because people are scared it's
because I genuinely think people should
be prepared I don't think it makes sense
to this is why I only do it a couple
times per year maybe like five or six
it'll be like there's a major storm or
blizzard happening be hey guys you
should have emergency food here's an
example as to why you should do it right
now it's pretty wild because I believe
Costco has analytics on on uh on sales
and Distributors I bet they go to one of
their warehouse Distributors and they
pay for data on what's coming and going
so you get a regional Warehouse like
where do donuts come from from your
favorite doughnut shop well small ones
may bake the donuts but the truth is
there will be like I don't know if
Dunkin Donuts does this but there will
be one big Factory that will produce a
bunch of donuts and then ship them out
to all the stores if you have a regional
Warehouse distributor maybe like Cisco
does these things for restaurants uh
actually a good example is uh
skateboarding I I don't want to speak to
any other industry I can speak I can
speak to how skateboarding works there
will be a warehouse the warehouse gets a
contract with all the big companies that
make Wheels bolts boards and they get uh
distributor prices local skate shops
then sign up to buy from that warehouse
that's how the system works so imagine
Costco goes to that warehouse and says
we will pay you $10,000 for all of your
sales numbers then they see holy crap
emergency food bins are skyrocketing we
carry this we make Bank yeah and
especially since they're someone who's
really particular about what they sell I
think this speaks to uh a change in
American culture right now which is that
people the average person who shops at
Costco is saying I want to be prepared
again it doesn't have to mean Civil War
or anything else it could just mean like
I noticed last year we lost power a
couple times I noticed last year we
couldn't get to the grocery store
because the the snow was too bad on our
Hill like there are all kinds of Reason
be blaming climate change for sure sure
look I I hear what you're saying and and
I understand but I I would take the bet
the average person won't say it but they
think the end is nigh I wonder if they
want think the end is nigh or just
generally there is a distrust in the
system around around them there's this
movement towards self-reliance like you
get food to be prepared because you are
thinking about the future and that's a
shift away from our general culture of I
want to do things right now I'm only
going to think about right now that's
interesting in fact this should be an
extremely encouraging change in Costco's
policy because people who think about
the future are people you want around
you people who are preparing for you
know something bad to happen are
concerned about protecting themselves I
will say this maybe it's actually just
for like the past two years I've
basically made the pitch you don't need
the Apocalypse to buy emergency food and
I genu believe that's true whenever
whenever we would do these pitures I'd
say look like you know there's a
hurricane coming make sure you have
emergency food but the reality is you
don't buy it because you think the world
is ending you buy it because sometimes
it rains and there have been instances
where the power's gone out for several
days in New York when uh Hurricane Sandy
hit Lower East Side was without power
for a while and a lot of spoed foiled OT
SP a lot of SPO a lot of food has
spoiled uh and uh if if people had
emergency food in their houses they'd
have been totally fine oh we'll just
crack at the the old stock pile but the
uh the thing about these these these
meals is you don't eat them you don't so
if you have them you only eat them when
you absolutely have no choice so like uh
you go to like one of these um like
fortitude Ranch for instance is like an
emergency I don't call it a bunker it's
more like a outdoorsmanship time share
because in the event the apocalypse
happens sure you can go there but
they're like yeah we have emergency food
but before you ever go into that you are
foraging you are hunting you are you are
finding other ways you are farming and
then when the winter hits and your crop
was bad you crack up in the emergency
food yeah there there are things you buy
for the future and or you buy them
because you don't know when you'll need
them and you don't want to be in a
position where you're without resources
and I think that's again extremely
interesting people who are are saying
everything's fine I I don't need to be
prepared for the future are also saying
I believe that everything that's going
on right now is okay and I think the
majority of people don't feel that way
Mr Jay super chated that Costco has been
selling those in Texas for a long time I
was going to say one of the most
interesting things would be to see a
state-by-state breakdown of which ones
are they sh their project reg I imagine
it's probably being sold in Utah as well
cu the LDS church teaches people to
stockpile significantly in case of you
know storms or anything else that may
happen the point however it's that
people who did not notice these before
are now noticing them so that you know
actually it's quite simple Costco said
hey you know we've been selling these
things in Texas and sales have been
skyrocketing let's start carrying them
in other stores I think we'll make money
capitalism baby yeah and now you can
look at it and be like why are people
buying so much of this because you're a
good salesman and we should all be
prepared no it could also be the thing
that for a lot of them like they were
there it's just that now they are
thinking about the end is n so they
noticed the emergency pack more now than
they would have when they were kind of
under the illusion that things were
better than they were before I think
that's a good cultural shift though in
general people should be buying things
like this on a consistent basis I mean
it just in my mind it's like people are
starting to trust the government less
and less which is of course a good thing
there's no negative when it comes to
that you actually don't need to buy
these things on a on a regular basis oh
no I mean I don't I can't speak
depending on the size or how long if
you're just like buying canned food to
prepare that's when you do regularly can
canned foods don't even last that long
to be honest but uh the the the
emergency buckets that we've pitched
last 25 years if they're stoed in stored
in a cool cool dry Place 25 years you
buy you buy one you never buy them again
your family grows remember when they uh
when the government released that list
of things that were like signs of IC
terrorist uh there was like uh
self-reliance canning your own Goods
making things like that anything that
involves yeah any type of homesteading
was labeled as farri extremist Behavior
okay I just saw this picture for the
first time oh that is awesome freeze
dried vanilla ice cream
sandwiches what do you do do you like
put it in a bowl of milk no you just
just eat it it like Aeros Space Museums
yeah
free I've had freeze dried ice cream
before it's like it's it's I don't know
it's like mering yeah it's like brittle
mering like breaks AP it's delicious
chewy delicious get one of these and do
a review on this show we can you
rehydrate it I imagine you could I don't
know I don't see why you
couldn't have to freeze it again
obviously though yeah once you
rehydrated it you just stick it in the
snow yeah what would happen free would
the ice cream just turn like if you
rehydrate would just turn a liquid yeah
that's why I think so and then you'd
have to freeze that again and then you'd
have like reconstituted ice cream which
I don't know why you do that I bet if
you dipped it in milk it would be
awesome yeah it probably would be I I
have never done that but I learned that
uh full grown cows make up to like 12
gallons of milk per day yeah yeah MH
That's crazy dude there is something
hilariously dystopian about the idea
that it's like the end of the world is
coming and the the businessman is just
there like unbeknownst to anything he's
oh people want to buy stuff for the end
of the world I guess I'll selling stuff
for the end of the world that's fine
it's uh it goes on I love it and then
the businessman is using the money he
gets to prepare for for the end of the
world EXA it's perfect he's the one
building the but there are companies
that were like oh you're I mean I
remember seeing these videos in like
2012 when people people be like I own a
company that will build you a bunker I
have this model it's like getting a a
pre sure like I don't think it's
necessarily bad for people to sell these
types of things if you can do it it's
just interesting that it has become so
mainstream Costco was like I think the
average Suburban family might buy one of
these meal family meal man that's like
who is shopping at Costco you know like
it's it's just people who are regular
average Americans who might look at it
and say this this is worth having again
good cultural shift well well I have
good news maybe it never gets to that
point we have this from cnr.com White
House reportedly wants to replace kamla
Harris acknowledging Biden is in Decline
this comes from the Intrepid work of
James O'Keefe who uh had this is this is
one of the most brutal undercover
investigations he's done in my opinion
but it is newsworthy it is important and
it is the fault of the the target of the
sting operation or whatever you want to
call it the
investigation okay so basically James
goes on a date I guess with a guy and
the guy dressed as clerk Kent dressed as
clerk Kent he basically he puts on what
do you put on like a vest and glasses he
should have parted his hair the opposite
way just Parts the other direction am I
crazy and thing he tweeted the other day
like what if I dyed my hair more glasses
and wanted recogniz probably that after
proba already I hope so so so look this
a top White House cyber security
official speaking with James O'Keefe in
Disguise James was just wearing glasses
in Disguise Dy his hair like his tweet
these people are not smart here's what's
important no this guy says they've had
discussions about removing K Harris but
they can't because she's the first black
multiracial VP and she's next in line
something everyone on the right has
acknowledged they won't say publicly we
know they have already discussed it he's
also acknowledged but the signs of
Biden's decline are there but he's not
been clinically diagnosed with dementia
and this guy look I'm watching this
video from James and I feel real bad for
him I feel bad for this guy but I don't
feel bad enough to where I care because
he works in the executive office of the
White House these things that are being
said must be said to the American people
yeah and the only way we can learn about
the fears that the White House has with
their failing and ailing president is
when someone privately says it they
won't go public and say listen the
American people we're we're concerned
about this to be fair fine security
issues May freak people out a
functioning government and Country in my
opinion knowing that Joe Biden was
incapable would remove him they would
come out and say we need him to step
down 25th amendment we're getting rid of
him but they don't want to because they
don't want to lose power in the end
James makes the best point you work in
cyber security for the White House and
then he takes his glasses off and goes
why are you having a meeting with James
O'Keefe and the guy's like oh yeah I've
heard of you and he's like you're just
telling me everything and I was like
yeah I feel bad in the sense that this
guy thought he was going on a date and
he was just going to have a good time
and then spilled all the beans I don't I
don't feel well no but I on a personal
level it's like you know it's some guy
he's goingon to have some wine with
James you thought you were going on date
turns out you're being set up like but
here's the issue fun here's here's a
here's here's a question when I was
watching this with my girlfriend and
immediately she goes does he have
clearance and I was like oh man not
anymore right I bet he did and he's
saying yo you can't go out and tell a
random person from the White House
Office we've discussed having KLA Harris
be be replaced on the ticket that's H
know that it's like they know that it's
James o'keef so they just use it to
plant false information I don't think
they're that smart you're giving them
too much of the there's a thing like
when like when they were promoting the
like Man of Steel they had Henry caval
sit directly under a Superman post and
nobody recognized him and I I think
people know James's name but not
everyone knows his his face I mean
because some of his work is done by
other undercover reporters and stuff
like that and James points out I mean
look they're they're working cyber
security they should know who James
o'keef is you would think well and if
they are working cyber security and if
he is prominent in cyber security it
would most likely be a top secret
security clearance that he has that he
just burned on camera in front of how
many views does that have now I mean
probably Millions at this point it was
trending takes off the glasses he's like
oh I remember you from that oligarchy
music video yeah it's got you Carri one
podcast it's got 9.3 million views
that's just on the original post so his
his security clearance is burned at this
point I gu I need to stress guys look as
I'm watching this we were we're having
lunch um I had a chicken Caesar salad
blackened chicken it was incredible by
the way everyone agrees and uh I just
feel bad for this lonely guy who met
some dude probably on some dating app
and it was James O'Keefe the whole time
but what I love about this I'm sorry I
have to say it is the meme where it was
like if you are talking to a beautiful
woman it is James O'Keefe yes if you
work in Tech if you work for Democratic
organizations and the most beautiful
woman in the world is super into you
it's James O'Keefe this time this time
it was literally James o'keef I I bet
it's a super like that they get too it's
like not just a normal like but they hit
him with the super like the star pops up
and everything makes them feel all giddy
inside then they go on the date and just
get absolutely burned on a national
level I think this needs to be stressed
though my point as as much as I felt bad
James broke one of the biggest stories
of the year right here with an someone
who works in the White House outright
saying we have had meetings about
replacing K Harris on the ticket yeah we
are not going to but they've
acknowledged that she is unpopular and
can't win that is massive massive uh
scoop that James O'Keefe got by doing
this but there's the party of unity and
coming together together it's just crazy
to me that the Democratic president
can't pull us off I mean this is it's
it's nice to have confirmation for a
thing I think everyone suspected but
really hopefully this is a video that
you play to anyone who's moderate or
left in your life and say this is from
your own camp this is someone who
actively supports Biden they work in his
White House and they're saying the VP
and president are Fray at best and also
no one likes this VP and also we think
he has dementia this is your strong
leadership for the nation right now is
this what you want I I feel like you but
at the same time a lot of these people
are so disillusioned they'll take like
the Mark Cuban stance of like you edit
your videos like this has to be edited
deep fake it's AI something along that's
the frustrating thing about Ai and like
all the def stuff is that it just makes
it easier for all kinds of people to
deny the truth in this case you know I
think there are people who would not
trust James O'Keefe just be out of
personal bias right they don't they
don't trust anything he does but the
Biden Administration can't hide the fact
that they are in a rough position I mean
when we talk about Biden's Health they
they delay releasing his physical every
year later and later and I swear that
doctor who signs it must just be sort of
like lying he just conducting it on
himself he's just like well he's holding
the he like last year this was the thing
like the last one came out there's a
specific line about Biden's gate and
people will say it's like a dementia
Shuffle there's there's a sign that this
is this is what's happening and uh he
was like yes his gate has stiffened but
really not that much and it's actually
fine and this is the thing that they do
over and over again like we acknowledge
that you might be seeing something but
you're insane for thinking it's it's
actually a good thing you're acting
crazy he started shuffling because the
weight of the far right extremists are
just bearing him down and how dare you
question him I do appreciate look like
it's it's there's a a bit of
confirmation bias that I think everybody
has like the idea of pointing out
there's edits in this video that's
actually a good instinct to have for
everyone you should apply that same
logic to the people who make content
that you agree with as well you should
be looking for the uh where the video
starts where the video ends are there
Cuts in here is there something that's
being removed it's just it seems most
people can only seem to apply that when
they already disagree with the point
they're not willing to look critically
at the stuff they agree with in the same
way and I think that you open yourself
up to a lot more information if you're
willing to do that the other big scoop
here which may not apply to to today but
is very relevant is that he said I had a
meeting with Michelle Obama an intern he
said someone asked her he said when I
was an intern someone asked her will you
ever run for office and she said no
emphatically no I've seen all the ish my
husband has uh has had to do go through
and it does not interest me so many
people have pointed out Michelle Obama
does not want to
run he said Biden will be the nominee K
Harris will be the VP on the ticket and
that's what they will play and it's just
kind of like maybe this guy did know who
James was the whole time and they're
baiting him because yo Biden can't win I
understand that we were saying this in
2020 so I will gladly say knock on wood
you never know what's going to happen
but at the time Biden actually was
winning in the polls and we were in
disbelief the polls could be right and I
think we were mostly correct the polls
were not right and due to very clever
what we call it Shadow campaigning is
what time magazine called it Joe Biden
wins the presidency as how I'll describe
it Shadow K I think right now you know
when Ian is talking about how his
parents are like man this migrant crisis
is crazy I'm like Biden's losing the
normies how are they going to maintain
the facade well I even have like what I
would consider normies within my family
my extended family whenever I'm you know
around they're asking me about this
because they're seeing some of my
reporting or they're seeing what's going
on with the border and that's always
what they want to talk about is the
Border because that's what they find the
most interest in and you know they talk
about you know how our taxpaying dollars
going towards this and it genuinely
makes them mad so and I see this happen
over and over again whenever I'm at
family events and I'm like okay so
people that usually don't pay attention
to politics or usually don't even follow
my work within my family are now
noticing you know so the noticing is
high nowadays I would say I think part
of it is that people feel the economic
pressure I mean they no one thinks Biden
has done a good job on the economy if if
you talk to normal people things are not
are tough and so to hear on top of that
that not only do we send money abroad
but also when we spend money
domestically it's actually on people who
are not here legally it must be
infuriating I mean that's that's the
conversation everyone's going to have
with themselves now it's like is this is
this working and Trump Trump's strongest
thing has always been immigration and
it's never been something Biden can
handle so real quick just on the other
story about the uh migrants at the
airport I've got some photos sent to me
that are a little bit clearer but
there're just screenshots he is
definitely wearing a brown round yeah
you can clearly see it and his Insignia
in his arm is a Drill Sergeant insignia
it would appear so no idea what that
means but that would imply the this is
not National Guard it could be that he's
just in transit or something but why
would he stop someone from filming
illegal immigrants and why would he be
sitting outside the door in that way and
in his own little rly chair as well yeah
he's not just sitting in a chair that
happens outside of it let's just say
maybe he's just uh just traveling and
he's sitting in this random chair has
nothing to do with anything and decided
to stop the guy from filming just
because no idea I mean I could
understand if you thought someone was
filming you being like hey stop but in
this case it doesn't seem like he is
just sort of waiting for a flight it
seems like this is an inent no place
that he is he is lingering now when I'm
in the airport I don't care if people
are filming either so I actually have
had a few situations where you know you
have some Karens come up to you as
you're filming these illegal immigrants
and they'll try and stop you and it's
always hilarious cuz you know my my
cameraman Juan poor Juan he tries to be
nice with them and I just immediately
flip the switch and it's like get out of
my face but I say it a lot more angry
and then they immediately kind of shut
down and they can't like even fathom
that you're telling them to just leave
you alone so I can do my job but if I'm
just a random dude in the airport and I
see somebody filming I'm not going to go
up to you especially if you're filming
something that's totally unrelated to
you and yeah maybe you're in the
background of it I'm not saying you know
I I learned something uh very important
about these protesters from owning a cat
so you know you get these protesters
they come up to get in your face when
you're trying to film and they're just
trying to obstruct you and so whenever
my cat comes up to me and is you know
being annoying whatever I
just just blow on him mhm you just blow
on them and they go away and there you
go and the protest you start blowing in
their face and stop what are you doing
and they try to hold their hand in front
of your camera whatever you just blow on
them they'll go away actually I'm
kidding don't do that I don't know what
the legality is of blowing on I think
you'd be fine how are you going to prove
that I was blowing on you I was
breathing I was I took a big breath in
you know strong exhale you close enough
to feel my breath on your face you're
too close being filmed you pulled the
camera out he's like if bucko is
annoying you you just pull out the
camera and he immediately goes away yeah
but it but in the video that we saw from
D it's wild that people are like stop I
just got to say these people are evil
look you go to a trump rally walk out
the camera and you've done it and what
happens they crowd around in excitement
and say oh look at me I want to talk
about why I care about America and
here's what I want to do and here's
everything I believe in they have
nothing to hide I stand by these things
yeah and then you go to the left and
they're like quick shut them down people
are going to find out what we're really
up to well it's just like at protests
that turn into riots they will not allow
filming at all because they know what is
going on is illegal and they want it to
remain hidden so well it's not not just
that it's illegal they know that if the
public finds out what they're doing that
they will lose public support so there's
there's a lot of memes about this but
this is what I experienced with Occupy
Wall Street there's a famous video where
Occupy Wall Street put this video out
and it's a cop swinging his baton
violently at people and they made the
Baton turn into a lightsaber very smart
and they were like not it was a double
layer scop the idea was a cop attacked
protesters we are going to make fun of
him everyone shared the video so people
start sharing this video of the cop with
the Baton going and they're like hahaa
what they don't show you is the cop got
attacked first by Occupy Wall Street
protesters riers at that point knocking
down a barricade and then knocking his
head off and shoving him and then he
starts pushing with The Paton then
swings when I'm down there and I'm
filming this and it's raw and live
streamed they're getting pissed off
because now regular people get an
archive of exactly what happened
protester attacked
cop attacks protester not cop randomly
attacks protester don't get me wrong
cops also randomly arrest random people
too and lie about it not going to defend
them on that one but in this context
yeah everyone's trying to win some
agenda by controlling the flow of
information it's the Ryan long bit where
he's like I take the footage of the cop
attacking the protester I sell it to CNN
I take the footage of the protester
attacking the cop I sell it to Fox and
the best part is like once I
accidentally sent he said once I
accidentally sent video of protesters
picking up garbage uh to Fox News and
they got mad said what's this I said
just play in Reverse it looks like
they're littering
[Laughter]
that was a good one just playing looks
like they're littering yeah that was a
great bit how he can sell the same
footage to both news agencies and but
you it really is true though like in my
experience of Licensing footage like you
license certain footage to when I was
independent you license certain news
organizations want to see C like
different things so the violent stuff
you know clearly goes to Fox and the
more right-wing organizations and then
you know the O Rah raw the speeches and
stuff that's what the leftwing org
ganizations want to see so there there's
a lot of truth behind that yeah but like
if you get a video of a cop whacking a
protester MSNBC is going to be like name
your price you get video of a protester
whacking a cop Fox News says name your
price yep to be fair though you know I'm
being a little bit hyperbolic Fox is
absolutely more fair that's just of
course they want that hey this is going
to do really well on TV so we want this
video where the cop is being hit or
whatever but in my experience these left
lefting organizations will shut you down
in two seconds if The Narrative is
outside in any way and fox will will run
whatever want say a perfect example of
that is after January 6 after I
documented the shooting of Ashley
babbett Fox at least Laura Ingram they
licensed my video and I went on and
actually appeared and I told them what
happened she wasn't being violent she
was actively trying to deescalate and
then all the left-wing organizations
they scheduled an interview with me
after they licensed my footage and then
they cancelled last second and then ran
with their own narrative that was
completely wrong
yep yeah that's how it works
I think that's why people become
disenfranchised with with the media
right they see the same video appear in
different places without context and I
think that's what I find so interesting
about the ecosystem that's appeared I
mean you're definitely a huge part of
this of uh independent journalists or
you know people who start off on just
kind of because they want to know they
want to be on the ground I think Tim is
similar in this respect uh who can tell
you well this is what was going on there
and you are able to connect with them
more directly through YouTube or X or
rumble or whatever uh you are more like
likely to believe the person who has
built themselves up than the person who
is just sort of suddenly appearing under
the brand name mainstream media logo and
saying no no don't question anything I
have it right yep hence why mainstream
media is dying at rates we've never seen
before and digital media at least
independent digital media is growing out
rates that we've also never seen before
shout out to tenant media so you know
someone super chated too saying basic
Army traines fly into Atlanta's uh uh
drill sergeants picked them up wish
there was more to it but probably not
the state senator said the army guy it's
US Army says took my phone it was a
scrimmage between he and I in order to
get the phone back and he proceeded to
tell me to get out of here and made a
big big scene out of it so it's like I
don't know man and maybe he's just
really pro- illegal immigrant may just
loves these people maybe he was just
there to pick up some you know trainees
and then he got asked hey can you watch
this room while you're waiting and he
was like sure I have no idea but I feel
like I hope this story makes it to
members of Congress who can launch an
inquiry and get someone to testify to
why this happened ask this state senator
to testify who like and we got to know
what this was about maybe it's just the
army guy of his own valtion was like I
don't like cameras okay maybe that's the
simplest explanation to me he just
didn't want to be filmed but
again we need context as to why this
person was there at all uh or why does
he happen to be in front of this room
full of you know criminal migrant I just
I don't get I don't get why so many
things are lining up if he were just
anywhere in the airport I would buy that
it was like I don't like to be filmed
but the fact is in front of this room
why would they have a drill sergeant
guarding a room exactly well you know I
don't like to be filmed but if someone's
filming me I'm not going to assault them
on camera to get them to stop filming me
that doesn't seem very logical my weird
he's like look I haven't done my makeup
yet I got to just get the camera off me
I don't know but I don't I don't I I I
don't want to believe that there is a an
official order that being said CBP is
actively engaged in human smuggling mhm
I don't it wouldn't be surprising at
this point it really wouldn't be with
the the Roe of corruption and the rout
of cartel and NGO money flowing around
because it is a lot more I mean the the
NGO that I was at was San Antonio PD
their Federal funding I think it went
from 10 million to like 70 million year
by year so the amount that they're
getting and then the amount that they're
basically hiding and straight up
laundering is insane it grows year by
year so this is huge money for anybody
involved dude I think that's like the
big thing that shakes a lot of people
that are like the old school classic
Democrats Doo is when you tell them you
to explain how much money they're
getting and how much just going nowhere
this may be a substantially larger
Scandal than we yet realize I will
stress maybe is a lot of nothing but we
got a Super Chat and this is from uh let
me see here we go uh let's see which one
was I just
reading uh this this one's big so I want
to make sure I get it right
right BQ says Tim to be honest it looks
like a group going to boot camp I was
stuck in an unmarked room at an airport
until my flight was ready however there
were volunteers from a group called team
libertad which boasts helping migrants
travel on social
media I think the pieces line up pretty
perfectly that criminal aliens are being
trained to join the armed forces well
there's been a lot of interviews too
where people talk to these uh criminal
aliens that are coming over and they're
like what did you do in your home
country and they straight up say we're
soldiers like that is what we did I mean
you have dozens of these interviews
happening so I would not put it past
them trying to recruit especially the
recruitment numbers being so low if
you're allowing them into the country
illegally why wouldn't you want them to
join the Army you have a room full of
migrants a whistleblower reported to a
state senator Republican state senator
in Georgia who went there and filmed and
saw team libertad in fact you can see
team libertad on his shirt with a
lanyard an organization which boasts of
helping migrants travel on social media
with a drill sergeant out in front
apparently guarding the room and trying
to stop the guy from filming the most
likely scenario criminal aliens are
being offered join the US Military and
they're heading to training doesn't look
good I don't know that's true I'm not
saying it is I'm saying that seems to be
the most plausible scenario here and
we've predicted this as a possibility
many people have that US military
numbers recruitment numbers are way down
way down people don't want to join up
and they may have found their way to
bolster the numbers could it be the
reason the Costco is selling more food
World War III is potentially on the
horizon Iran uh is about to be Biden's
going to attack Iran and so they're like
we don't know or care where we get them
from we need as many troops as possible
these are going to be low tier guys they
can drop on the front lines but what do
they care man I remember when I was
trying to join the Army out of high
school I had to get my hand tattoo
lasered off because they wouldn't give
me a special waiver and now here we are
potentially recruiting illegal
immigrants let's jump to this story
ladies and gentlemen once again in the
news Ben Shapiro's new song Hit number
one on iTunes how did that happen but I
want to stop you right now this segment
is not about Ben chapiro rapping we've
talked about that ad nauseum it does
revolve around the issue of bench PE
rapping but it has more to do with how
the narrative machine is fake how they
trick you into thinking demonic
degenerates are popular I'm driving in
the car and we hear that song from Sam
Smith I forgot what it's called but it's
a song about how the dad is secretly
abandoning his family to have gay orgies
that's actually what it's about you know
do you know the song No with the
transgender singer sounds like Sam Smith
look it
upim Kim Petrus is that what it's called
no it's with Kim Petrus is on the song
it's called Body Shop yeah it's
basically Sam Smith is singing that
there's a guy and his family is unaware
that he ditches them and and disappears
to go to Bath hous and have gay orgies
I'm like literally what the song's about
that takes like going out for milk and
not coming back to a whole another level
now here's the important thing cool you
see these people perform at Big award
ceremonies you see Lil Nas acts uh uh uh
you know insult
Christians fate the devil I he I guess
he did that in like one of his music
videos and they want you to believe it's
popular you get Nicki Minaj and you get
like Megan D Stallion and they want you
to believe that WAP and things like this
are popular but what we're learning now
thanks to Tom McDonald is exactly how
it's fake and this is important to
understand don't believe the
manipulations Washington Post breaks
down this the the the the con game they
don't break it down they they exemplify
it but Tom McDonald here in this video
explains exactly how they are lying to
you now what Tom's Video is about is the
music IND industry is cheating I want to
play this minute clip from Tom McDonald
but then I want to elaborate on what
he's saying here's the here's the clip
I'm going to show you guys how the music
industry cheats on the charts and I
guarantee you didn't know this this is
the iTunes charts that's my song Facts
featuring Ben Shapiro at number one you
see how Megan the stallion has two
versions of the same song at number two
and number three you see how Nicki Minaj
has eight versions of the same song at 4
6 8 16 17 19 20 and 23 you ever wonder
why they do that every song has an ID
number called the UPC code this code is
what billboard uses to count song sales
if you release multiple versions of a
song you can use the same UPC code for
every version that means Nicki Minaj's
eight versions count as one song when
billboard collects the numbers we're
competing against 10 songs and all 10
versions are going to be combined into
two songs seems pretty unfair doesn't it
yeah that's the music industry that's
why we need everyone who sees this to go
download facts on iTunes or Amazon
billboard stops collecting our numbers
in 24 hours this is our last chance to
lock in that number one on Billboard go
get those downloads of facts by Tom
McDonald and Ben Shapiro on iTunes or
Amazon we'd sure appreciate it guys
thanks for the help I'm going to show
you guys let me let me let me break this
down a little bit further Tom Tom's
Point pointing out how let me see if I
can get there you go this is true and
we've dealt with this too you a lot of
people will release a song and then
they'll release a remix at the same time
that's one song even though they're
completely different yeah so what I'm
talking to Carter about I was like let's
do a song and record it in four
different genres let's do acoustic folk
let's do New Wave retro let's do hard
rock and let's do country and it's one
song and we can make the one song for
everybody this is the game they play the
reason why it's important Megan the
stallion what is it Bigfoot that song is
going to hit the top of the charts all
of the woke media is going to oh haha
she beat Ben Shapiro she's so much
better and bigger or whatever reason and
it's through these manipulative games
they want you to believe the most
popular music among young kids these
days is degenerate filth when in reality
that's not true it's technically true
and that's another thing that's pointed
out by The Washington Post again I know
a lot of people are like I don't care
about benj PE rapping fine F fine that's
not the point the point is what we're
learning they in this article they talk
it talks about like what's going on with
the song and they have this really uh
important part who is M McDonald has he
had hits before they say this is facts
really a hit no no no hold on it's
number one on iTunes
worldwide why would the Washington Post
even ask that question what's the
implication it's not no no for real if a
song is number one on the iTunes charts
and the Amazon charts right now
worldwide for what purpose would
Washington Post actually ask this
question this is priming they want
people to think it may not really be
ahead but here's what they say this is
important facts held the number one spot
on iTunes music as of Wednesday January
31st sitting ahead of Megan the stallion
his and Nicki Minaj's Bigfoot according
to Apple I did they have that backwards
I thought uh Bigfoot was oh that is
Nicki Minaj okay they say according to
Apple iTunes numbers are calculated by
what songs are downloaded and bought
through iTunes different than Apple
music which purely measures streams
streaming numbers paint a different
picture as of Wednesday morning the song
had just over 1 million listens on
Spotify on Apple music the song hadn't
cracked the top 100 songs in the country
Apple did not share data about the
song's overall streaming numbers they go
to mention label artists have access to
playlisting and resources that
Independents do not said McDonald on the
song success on iTunes compared with
streaming if we want to compete with
them on the Billboard charts this is the
way to do it yada yada y I think they
mentioned the number
of the here we go Megan the stallions
fact has 9.7 million views on YouTube
and uh his from Megan the stallion has
8.2 million on YouTube and the Bigfoot
Audio Video has 3.7 million views on
Minaj's page here's the point they're
asking the question is it really a hit
because they are trying to set up
manipulative narrative control what we
are seeing right right here I can break
down for you how they trick you the
Apple streaming numbers when they say oh
you know Tom McDonald didn't even hit
the top of the charts that's too bad do
you want to know how you get on top of
the charts you're a major label
producer your label goes to the charts
and says your modern music pop chart
must have this in rotation x amount of
times per
hour how would Tom McDonald compete with
them saying default play on the
streaming service imagine if every time
you went to YouTube the only thing you
could see was timcast IRL we would have
billions of views and we'd be like well
you know we're the biggest podcast in
the world cuz we're the best no it's
because the service put you in front now
it may be that these streaming services
are just like it's the easy route these
are Big famous artists we hear about
hear about hear about them in the news
so we we put them in our uh Digital
streaming playlists and when the average
person signs up for the first time this
is what they get you go to YouTube music
This Is What You Get
why power attracts power if you I have
to wonder why it is I talked about this
before you know there was a song by
Paramore which is has 6 million views
after a year and they're playing it at
the Hard Rock Hard Rock seminal in in uh
Miami and I'm like this song is not
popular culturally relevant no no dis to
parore I'm a big fan of Paramore but I'm
like it's not one of their biggest songs
ever why is it being played it's just
easy to give them a default position
here's the real the reality of what
matters do you sell do you make money
right now no question
Tom McDonald and Ben Shapiro have made
substantially more money off this song
in terms of consumption of the song than
Nicki Minaj Did and Megan D stallion
done that's it so what are we really
measuring the machine has set up the
creative arts industry movies or
otherwise in such a fashion that they
have fabricated and
manufactured popular music that is not
actually popular it's been this way for
a long time it's worse today than it's
ever been with with streaming services
but the main issue here is the songs
they're putting out and claiming are
popular are very often degenerate guns
guns guns shots shots shots doing drugs
all this really awful stuff and they
want you to believe it's
popular it's not no I don't think it is
I I find you know because you guys
released a song in December and now this
one's coming out with it with um bench
pero I find it a really interesting
experiment because if we had all kinds
of people sort of in alternative media
space doing these kinds of music uh
every month they're going to pretend
that no no this one's not a hit you know
the more information you get about the
system works the more the better
prepared you are to sort of launch a
song and try and catch them in their own
games at a certain point they're making
it more obvious what they're doing by
denying everyone who attempts to come in
from the outside uh it's just a really
expensive experiment I would assume is
it really a hit that question is
incredible right yeah I think the fact
that it's the number one song in the
world on iTunes means it is but they're
going to say it's not which is
interesting because I think this is
something that they'll do over and over
again I mean they're only going to be
more musical artists who now are saying
well I want to try and get on Bill
Billboard Hot 100 and again the more
obvious it becomes that they're shutting
certain kinds of people out basically
functionally discriminating against them
the more invalid their data becomes
because that's what gets me that they
they weigh the the different streams at
different amounts meaning that it
doesn't matter what people are actually
listening to it just matters who was
ultimately letting their pockets the
film industry did this over the summer
with sound of freedom in much the same
way uh much the same way that they point
out that like look they're spending $250
million on movies that don't even break
a quarter of what they need to even
break even let alone profit but when
sound of Freedom came out they actually
started to call into question the way
that they were fundraising to make you
think that people didn't actually want
to go see this movie they're saying like
well people are buying tickets but
people aren't really going to the movie
they were saying that dude and and
wasn't it crazy how many people said the
power went out yeah the air conditioning
went out I know people personally who
are like the theater shut it happened to
several people that I know here in in
Maryland well they're not just doing
this same thing to you know bencha and
this other artist but they've done it to
Bryson gray they've done it to when
Trump released the or they released the
song with the Trump soundtrack over for
the J Sixers they did the exact same
thing with that they did to us a month
ago exactly so it's a very I mean just
like what Hannah said how many times are
they're going to keep doing this denying
reality is their MO and it's not just in
this industry it's in the movie IND it's
anytime conservatives try to have a like
true cracken culture because they want
to control the narrative and they for
one I think a big play is destroying
Christianity I'm not a Christian but
come on the stuff they're promoting it's
just like very on the nose look at
little NS X is uh most recent it's like
him being crucified in the music video
as he says I'm a Christian it's like no
you're not well and Sabrina Carpenter
got in trouble for filming that music
video in the Brooklyn uh the cathedral
and they came out and they like purified
The Altar and everything because for
whatever reason it's okay to treat
Christians like the other and to mock
their religion but you wouldn't do it to
anyone else I think that in some ways
this is what turns Americans off from
mainstream music whether it be pop rap
whatever genres it's like anything
that's playing on the radio when you're
constantly hearing like be
hypersexual hate everything around you
commit crimes like live a life that's
just falling apart you don't want to
listen to that I think it becomes uh
something you reject I think a lot of it
is I I think that most people are
listening to this stuff more passively
and they're not actually like we're
hyper analyzing what's going on here and
the average person is a consumer like to
the tea that term consumer they're just
consuming this stuff it is annoying when
they ask somebody who's not religious
either to watch them act like it's still
edgy as if they're pushing against some
type of institution that still has great
power here in America which as we know
within the entertainment industry that's
just not the truth anymore and acting as
if you're some type of re for hating on
Catholics or Christians is just it's not
just lame it's just unbelievably cringy
well it's the only religion that you can
actually go out and critique in the way
that they do look at what the drag
queens did or I don't even know what
they were called The Sisters of
something at the Dodger Stadium that's
perfectly okay and acceptable God forbid
you do that with Islam or any other
religion you're not allowed to do that
here and it just shows okay I mean the
the underlying symptoms of America's
disease I think is a lack of
Christianity and the attack on
Christianity and they're doing it for a
reason is there is personally I believe
a lot of strength through Christ Christ
as Lord and they continue to do this
because what comes with Christianity
basic morals that's really all that it
is also for them there's a lot of
marxist beliefs that are tied in there
with where they believe the power
structure here is in America where
you're allowed to criticize this group
because you fall lower or higher on the
oppression scale than someone else does
and unfortunately those groups are
always going to be fair game to them I
just find it unbelievably lame that they
still believe it's I would almost have
more respect if they were doing it but
not talking about it as if they were
like somehow sticking it to the Man by
doing it I'm like you're the man you're
the system now I think what you said
before about passive consumption is is
right I think most of these record label
streaming things you know it's like we
always make fun of CNN because it's
playing in like empty airports Across
the Nation like this stuff is playing on
the radio you know radio actually does
get a fair amount of attention but it's
just playing in the background for a lot
of people lives I think really though
people are waking up to it and saying
like I don't want to listen to this I
mean I've listened to I've gotten gotten
and totally told by a lot of women like
oh yeah I was feeling really anxious
feeling depressed and then I stopped
watching shows that just drove my
anxiety I gave up true crime they
stopped watching The True Crime show
right right I mean it's not just True
Crime it's all kinds of stuff but you
know when you consume content that is
negative ultimately even if it's at a
fast beat or whatever you think like you
are ultimately warping your perspective
and I think people don't want that right
now not to uh backtrack sorry Tim but uh
I had an army us uh retired army veteran
comment the CCH and seen in that video
in the daily callar story 194th armor
rade from Fort Moore so it is the Army
wow I want to point this out too uh in
the article they uh Tom McDonald says
we're outperforming her in every metric
they're not allowing us to pass Megan
and hit the number one spot right now
they said the song is number three
trending on YouTube behind his and
Bigfoot despite outperforming them in
every metric is a lot of it also just
like there's there's incentives and
there's bonuses that are attached with
artists reaching certain levels and the
industry is insulated in a way that
allows them to find success under their
own metrics so they can bolster their
own artists like these labels right I
mean yeah it's not just music it's
commercials TV yes it's I'm not just
like we're talking about the cultural
impact I'm thinking of it from the
business impact that there's just
there's a financial incentive to keep
people out not just from a cultural
standpoint but from a financial
standpoint they want to be able to
charge $50,000 to license their song
that means their song has to be the
biggest song that means they're going to
make 20 versions of it they're going to
have I mean this look think about this
we've never done this should we should
we the next song we put out create 10
versions of the same song that are
slightly different in some way do it in
see as a as an experiment see what
happens cuz look so here's what happens
when we released together again we put
it through what called the uh direct to
customer uh uh uh music uh company
there's a bunch of companies that say we
create your band page you can upload
your music people can buy it straight
through here we say okay we'll do that
they changed the rules mid last year to
stop counting them and they did it
quietly I mean how are supposed to know
now it's iTunes and Amazon only so I I I
I forgot kind of where I was going but
that's oh so so what ends up happening
is we put the song out we don't know
this we get completely shut out they
don't tell us exactly what to do or how
to do it we have no idea they keep
changing it so that only those who are
in the labels and know the industry are
able to adapt to it
properly that's wild the Nicki Minaj
Hong was legitimately just one of the
worst things I've heard in almost every
insulting like they don't have to put
out anything that's good they just have
to be just have to say we want this song
out here's what I was going to say when
we put it out on the direct to customer
uh website it's 69 cents for the song
but you can choose to pay more tons of
people were giving us five bucks I'm
like okay I appreciate it how about we
just release five versions of the song
so one person can be five sales now yeah
I I I will tell you this right now if we
multiplied our sales by five and did it
through iTunes we would be Billboard Hot
100 number one yeah we we we'd be number
one I think this is this is the play I
think if that's if Megan the stallion or
Nicki Minaj did this all these different
versions I think that's what we got to
do yeah man because then I can say
everybody it's like hey man you gave me
10 bucks for this one song I really
appreciate the appre appreciate the
support just buy it 10 times
$6.90 and one person is a whole album
sale now a whole album we would easily
get 100 to 200,000 sales if we mult I
mean I got to be honest if we did 10
versions we' get get 300,000 sales we
would be Billboard Hot 100 number one
yeah be rad let's do it it's just wild
that you have to do that like you can't
just put out a song that is good that
people like you instead you have to game
the system so they'll let you in I know
it's just sad that that's like cuz
they'll represent this as this is the
most popular song in the country it's
it's everywhere it's whatever but that's
not true think of the authors who would
buy their own books in quantity so they
could have the number the New York Times
bestseller anyway exactly that's they've
all rigged their own systems it had to
be James nobody read his book but this
is the thing it just bothers me so much
that when they look at you know the
average consumer they're like this is
the nation's top songs and that's why
it's special to be on this list when
actually we've ConEd and manipulated it
as much as we can like you couldn't even
use this data to accurately report on a
song's growth because it's artificially
inflated that's crazy it's all rigged
it's all fake yeah but I've never really
followed the Billboard top 100 I will
say yeah it's just modern POA if anyone
knows like what what ited be it's just
POA ille is illegal it's illegal yeah
and it just hasn't hit the new the new
streaming market yet or hasn't been
applied to streaming I don't think it
can either but that's pretty much what's
going on that's why they know how to do
this the most important thing here is
again not it it you know when I want to
talk about this it's not because oh
here's a song They're rapping they
should be number one it's this is how
the narrative machine of of these woke
it corporate press Outlets manipulate
you into thinking these are the best
books these are the best songs they are
culturally engineering you to support
things that are detrimental to this
country and support communist BS we've
watched that like we watched it with the
show Reacher which got like no play from
the Press not in the same way because
they don't see any cultural influence
from it because the demographic is not
the it's the it's the straight white
guys the dads that are the ones watching
it so there's no ground to be made up on
that show but they push everything else
like rings of power because they can
make ground there we're going to go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and head over
over to
timcast.net
and if you've been a member for at least
6 months or you sign up for $25 a month
you can submit questions and call in to
talk to us and our guest live on the
show so uh definitely we could use your
support this show is made possible
thanks in part to viewers like you here
we go I'm not your buddy guy he's back
he says crazy people really know how to
screw up legitimate issues Tim's right
about violence please see BLM and Summer
of Love for case study finally I hope
people appreciate your sales 101 course
earlier yeah I was talking about uh I
was talking to Benny Johnson earlier
because he's got this tweet where he
said that Taylor Swift is a government s
up so I made a video was 40 minutes long
breaking down the it you know I'm just
I'm just going to say this there are
Republican politicians who are freaking
out that uh there are people like Jack B
Benny Johnson and others pushing this
narrative that Taylor Swift is a scop
because it is massive downside it is a
massive net negative and so I don't want
to speak about people's private
statements on this one but I think it is
the biggest mistake the right is making
right now yep there's no upside none and
I just want you to imagine what happens
FanDuel I believe it's FanDuel if you
Google search this you can bet on
whether or not Travis Kelce will propose
to Taylor Swift at the Super Bowl
it's it's it's a bet it's available I
think they're giving it um they're
giving it like plus 100 no no it's
likeus 250 they think it's going to
happen yeah imagine what happens if
Travis Kelce gets down on one knee and
as he's pulling the ring out a guy in a
Maga hat some fat guy in a white T-shirt
shoves him and says she's a SC out don't
believe her it's a trick it's all
scripted it would be every Swifty
rallying and screaming it would be the
it would be in the press for a week or
two weeks I'm not saying it's really
going to happen I'm just saying what's
the alternative that could happen if
someone came out and screamed at the
High Heavens it's a scop it recruits
nobody no but anyway not just that but
also like there's all the articles that
were going around today about Trump vers
Taylor Swift The Holy War like this is a
battle you're going to lose you will not
win this but I'm saying but it's a
losing issue first of all like Trump
needs to make up ground on female voters
anyways and they're talking about it
they're saying like is she going to
Endor by I'm like who cares she did it
in 2020 she's a
Democrat it's so irrelevant like the
thing is if you if everyone stopped
talking about it then she would just go
on to dat Travis Kelce maybe they're gon
get Super Bowl maybe they won't she's
not even in the country during the dnc's
National Convention and I don't care
it's just irrelevant and I don't care
that the Press is talking about it and I
don't care that she's at at the Super
Bowl my concern is that uh uh Jack and
Benny who are friends of mine are
pushing this narrative which is massive
detrimental to the right for no reason
well nobody wins I'll ask you a few
questions are swifties going to vote for
Donald Trump nope some some will some
will um like there is a a a we've had
someone on the show recently there is a
contingent of conservative women that do
like Taylor Swift but in large if we're
talking in general no they're not are
Trump supporters going to switch from
Donald Trump to Joe Biden because Taylor
Swift told him to no absolutely not our
mod
going to base who they vote for Taylor
Swift or Donald Trump based on whether
I'm sorry Joe Biden or Donald Trump
based on what Taylor Swift says in her
endorsement no maybe maybe not probably
not let's assume the answer is
no what's the upside to making enemies
you're not convincing Trump supporters
you earn no votes so there's a net neg
there's a net zero on that regard what
if the answer is yes will you convince
someone to vote for Donald Trump by
screaming at Taylor Swift as a
government scop or will you convince
some to vote for Trump by saying Trump
is going to secure the borders bring
back the uh improve the economy and oh
by the way we also love Taylor Swift
bring back the right-wing Taylor Swift
edits that's what we need we need to
embrace Taylor Swift there's nothing
wrong with that espcially if she's on
the brink of getting married to an
American football player after dating
all kinds of British guys for way too
long I'm sorry I already said it
pronatalist movement David gon says Tim
is assuming he is right and Benny Etc
are wrong though I'm not assuming it
shout out to Benny Johnson I'm a big fan
of his work he does great work were
friends but I got to call him out for
this he said on Twitter to what like six
seven million people it is confirmed
that Taylor Swift is a government scup
there are several things that are wrong
with this post one Taylor Swift did not
register 35,000 people to vote those
numbers are manipulated axio ran that
headline but if you actually read the
article they say the 35,000 number was a
23% increase from the previous year
meaning it's actually
8,17 if we could actually correlate
those numbers to Taylor Swift We can't
they go to mention that within they they
play this amazing game where they're
like it was a
1,226 increase the hour after tswift
made the post and we were getting 12,000
people every half an hour so you mean to
tell me that after Taylor Swift made a
post 272 million people 24,000 people
shut up to your website in an hour or or
and that was your massive increase
there's a poll that says one of Voters
would be would would be swayed by Taylor
Swift and she can swing the election
that same poll that headline is a Lie
the same article written by every
publication says the exact inverse would
happen if she endorsed Joe Biden 18%
would vote for him and 17% would would
vote against him giving her poll 1%
Benny Johnson also mentioned that George
that she came out as a liberal in 2020
that was 2018 He also mentioned George
Soros B music Soros invested with
Carlile group so that scooter Bron's
ethical Holdings could buy her music in
2019 which she then said I'm going to
re-record everything and they ditched
the investment a year later later
there's so much to this but guys that's
the point anyway we're going to move on
it's it's it's listen I'm going to put
it this way I've got Republican
politicians and staffers freaking out
over this saying why are they sabotaging
our Suburban our Suburban vote I don't
understand and I'm like me neither I
really don't get it there's there is no
nothing to be gained from from saying
this over and over over again doing
interviews about it but also there like
there's money to made by talking about
it right now unfortunately there's like
people who make media like there's
there's a financial incentive to talk
about it because her name is high search
engine optimization you're going to get
clicks talking the whole thing where she
was on field and whatever else it's not
just about the election it's about
making money
too yeah uh we'll just we'll just move
on from this because I just I can't
believe it man whatever the emperor's
Champion says Texas has my full support
Governor Abbott may have saved the
Republic with his actions Texas stands
yeah but what about Arizona and New
Mexico and California they're just going
to move everything over there so we'll
see mhm when the cartels are stepping
back and they're trying to figure out
how to reorganize these massive groups
that usually do go through Eagle paths
too so it's not like they're done it's
still going to happen they're just going
to push them up into a different sector
and do the exact same thing they've been
doing in Eagle Pass Jacob hly says did
you see the news drop for fton County DA
Fanny Willis insane it's on Benny
Johnson's YouTube absolutely effing
clown World which one was this one was
about the divorce or what
happened I don't know no I wasn't
following it today not sure all
right insert Amir says here's a white
pill for everyone ca's unconstitutional
ammo ammo background check scheme was
ruled unconstitutional by judge Benes
who immediately denied the request
requested stay by gruesome nome's uh
eigor uh Rob
bant I think you're trying to insult him
but I yeah a little too much
there uh let's see j3t says will Griff
cast mentioned Maga guy decapitating dad
I covered it for scnr news you guys
should there's not a lot to talk about
crazy guy commits murder gets arrested
calls for
violence declares himself president
declares himself he called himself the
Messiah and president and like requested
the Postal Service uh shut themselves
down or or else he would attack like he
was totally Wild and the thing is like
it is it is a flashy story he was
arrested alive so you'll hear more about
this just we're not talking about it
constantly right now doesn't mean it
goes away so he wants to get rid of the
postal service but not the FED he says
it's not state governments he just wants
to oh he just wants to uh he's anti- all
of the federal government and you know
he wouldn't compare himself to Jesus
Christ but he's saying that's why you've
never heard of him so all right Matt H
says Tim the woman's show should be
pro-natalist I think you'd really get a
show going that was focused on helping
new moms I like that I pretty sure
that's what it is be called
broadcast that's a really good idea
insinuates that they're dumb Noah no
we're going to we're going to take that
word back reclaim it like we need to
reclaim the problem is it's spelled the
exact same
way is that why it's not offensive like
it works out if we if we hyphenate it
the broadcast that's funny uh yeah but
the idea is to have like like post-
liberal libertarian and conservative
leaning moms and I wouldn't I actually
don't care if there's uh Democrats you
know what I mean like you'll have that
uh uh you know perspective
you get you bring a Democrat you you if
we took one Democrat woman and sat her
next to like four women who have like
regulars on timcast IRL within like
three weeks she'd be conservative dude
I'd be scared her brain would like
explode or something she would just be
like everything I thought was wrong yeah
that' be that' be I have learned the
truth
cool let's go what do we got we'll grab
some more Super
chats Michael McCord says Abbott needs
to charge Biden in mayorcas in Texas
under Texas state law Open Door with
Trump they should where's the Texas da
to file criminal charges against Biden
and uh uh uh
mayoras they they're trying to argue
that Trump is not immune okay criminally
charge Joe Biden right now for the
Border crisis do it you know what man
I'm just I'm sick of this stuff because
if I was if I was in any kind of uh like
Ada or AG or whatever in Texas Ken
Paxton come on this guy's got balls he
could do it I'd immediately be like
let's roll baby criminal charges send
them right on up and then I can say
what's your argu
is Joe Biden immune or is he not immune
because we got under his orders CBP
facilitating cartel human smuggling take
your pick baby yeah he's immune okay
we'll we'll we'll wait for impeachment
then oh that also means Trump can't be
charged either have a nice
day all right let's grab some more Super
chats so that happen says Texas Military
Department is actively recruiting if you
go to the Border join up and let the
state deploy you we most needed well
that's what I'm saying just go go
through the legal channels Abbott is
doing well I don't know if it's perfect
but uh from what I'm hearing from you
know Taylor for instance and others it's
way better now don't get in his way let
him do his
thing what do the kids say let him cook
that's right that's
right all right let's see Hein says I
created an AI Taylor Swift singing Sober
by Tool and sent on X peace okay wait
what's your Twitter handle how do I find
that yo I want to play this me choke oh
my gosh yeah great work as long as it's
not the other AI we've been seeing
recently do you remember that video of
it's it's uh Donald Trump and Baron in
the front seat it's Milani and
uh what Taylor's songs is playing like
that's what I'm saying Embrace Taylor
Swift that was like that was being
reposted today and say we used country
Taylor Swift sober we'll uh I'll play it
on the dude I love Sober by tul it's
like one of the best songs ever uh we'll
play it on the members only so shout out
to heand uh once we wrap the super chats
in 10 minutes everybody become a member
at Tim cast.com we're going to play an
AI version I hope it's good I haven't
heard it Taylor Swift singing Sober by
tulle dude I didn't even realize that
song is 31 years old yeah technically 33
because it was recorded 91 I thought it
was like mid to late 90s I didn't
realize that was that early that song's
too good to be that early do anemia next
yeah dude to tul is just absolutely
amazing big fan big fan
all right anyway we Taylor Swift singing
sober I'm so excited for that all right
here we
go Darth Sirus says Hey guys joining the
culture fight made a video with you in
mind can be found on all video platforms
Darth Sirus for rumble Darth dos serus
for Twitter is that Twitter and it's the
first one is serus with a zero instead
of an O right on man good luck good
luck Alles D says for the NG Troopers I
want to see name tapes and get unit info
go after the National Guard Leadership
and get his orders that'll tell you
where the push is coming from you get
info from the ground up I want to stress
this guys if that's potentially a group
being deployed for basic training with a
drill sergeant waiting outside and they
are criminal aliens being facilitated by
an NGO which it looks like it looks like
the US is taking them and sending them
to join the military M this could be a
massive Scandal don't know don't know I
might need to lay over in Atlanta on the
way some journalists on this one
yeah man uh I think we need uh I think
you need to team with James O'Keefe
figure this one
out do you have a pair of glasses you
could wear can James O'Keefe go under go
undercover as a migrant oh here's Josh
field says when you brought up UPS
either last night or the night before it
pissed me off when you said that UPS is
laying off drivers because of our great
contract they can't fire us union
members they are firing management no
right that I I didn't say otherwise my
point is if you have
$100,000 and you have 10 employees that
are each getting paid
$10,000 and then those employees all say
we want a raise and then they get a rais
to
$113,000 guess what you still only have
$100,000 which means in order to give
some of them a raise you have to fire
others in this instance sure firing
management right like this is this is
what happens but uh yeah if I wasn't
clear with that then thank you for for
uh super chatting so we have that
cleared up the people who are under
Union contract are being protected
uh I will also add I absolutely uh uh am
opposed to unions but I love collective
bargaining unions have become these
weird quasi corporate entities that have
weird rules about them which prevent you
from actually being able to exercise
your rights it's the craziest thing ever
yeah so it's like I I I've been in
several unions and uh hey I'd like to
get a promotion you can't Union contract
I'm like what what's the point of being
in Union if it's holding me back well
it's lifting others up okay well I don't
want to be a part of that Union then
well you have no choice the law says the
law says you can't we we we are allowed
to Bar you from being an employee here
unless you're part of the union and then
they have the right to work laws where
it's like you can't do that I agree with
that you can't force me to join the
union and then the left is like no
everyone must join the union dude I'm so
sick of
it I've I've not had any good
experiences with unions none neither I
but that's just me I'm not saying all
unions are bad I would just prefer
collective bargaining and not these
weird laws they have surrounding unions
like man he is not a fan take my
money all right Vos says speaking of IDW
Brett was on you're welcome today very
cool Victor papadopulos says take it
from anasi that you are giving Clare
Leman too much credit there were plenty
of journalists brave enough to call out
the covid lunacy but she wasn't one of
them yeah she was not and then her and
her ilk got into it with me and I was
right about everything yeah I remember
like right when that article came out
like we were talking about it downstairs
yeah because I'm like yo y you're
rounding people up from their houses and
locking them up and they're like but
it's comfortable and they did this
propaganda thing where they had models
in the in the like the forest and
tournament Camp they do like day in the
life like little influencers
vog the sandwich cart comes by and gives
you your prepackaged
meal it's a shame when journalists go
down that route especially journalists
that were doing good work cuz the whole
like the entire point of Journalism at
least what it used to be before
mainstream media happened and all this
dumb propaganda happened is to challenge
power oh they say earn money I mean now
I mean but journalists don't get paid a
lot unless you're you know signed with
mainstream Media or you're you know
pretty big in the industry but like the
whole point of Journalism and actual
reporting is to challenge powerful
people that's what it's all about oh say
sponsorship deals yeah yeah I mean now I
mean we should just make we journalists
same with like congressmen like Nascar
jackets with all their sponsors on it
that would be hilarious Jaz anut says
Tim talks about Australia like the whole
country as one city just because they
poop on the streets in SF doesn't mean
snap crap applies Nationwide don't smear
an entire country for what one state did
it wasn't just one state though may not
have been all the states but Australia
was not a good actor during Co wasn't a
Bastion of Freedom
yeah yeah they did Nationwide lock down
their borders and there were Australians
who couldn't come back in do you
remember that
phase born says my National Guard son
was asked to play concierge to concierge
to ID migrants in and out of NYC Hotel
take complaints for 3 months in Spring
of 23 op was pass to NGO interesting
wow wow Captain Titus says that's not
how clearances or classified information
Works he is probably fired but he
wouldn't lose his clearance well the
story just came out today 35,000
retweets like basically 10 million views
yo is it a huge it is it is a huge scoop
the White House was like we need to get
rid of Kamala Harris that's crazy and
that Michelle Obama is like I don't want
to run yeah I don't think they're going
to allow this guy to continue having
clearance to top secret information if
that's a clearance he has if he right
broke a story this large I agree it may
not be how it works but I also think
politically it may be however they feel
it should work yeah he's goingon to
suffer the consequences for sure Jake T
says you can be in the guard and a drill
sergeant I almost did it coming off of
active duty took the DD214 instead
interesting ex uh let's see X tinman
says maybe he's a DI escort escorting
illegals to boot camp for citizenship
for service right
that good point and uh too bad we didn't
see your Super Chat sooner but but uh
thanks for the Super Chat and I think
that that may be what we're seeing yeah
terrifying horri D they're already kind
of giving them citizenship though at
this point like you're just allowed in
and then you have court dates in 2032 so
you know if you feel like coming if if
you feel like showing up man we need we
need to get some members of Congress on
top of that we need we need to know what
that was and they may be trying to cover
it up cuz if it's true that they're
bringing these criminal aliens and
putting them in the armed forces you
know I said this as joking like send
them all to Ukraine there you go you
found your your troops that may be what
they're doing I mean imagine how twisted
it would be they invite these people
come to America you know the America
shining City on the hill awaits you get
here and they're like get on the bus
we're sending you to to Iran yeah I mean
I got to be honest militaristically talk
about a brilliant strategy MH convince
hundreds of thousands of people Millions
to come and then you just drop them off
in your enemy country well lotss of them
are former soldiers as well coming over
at least a single Mal so they'll fit
right in might not speak the language
but but the stay in a run they'll come
back and then they're entitled to the GI
Bill if they come back if they come back
if they don't come back okay fair enough
but they're not loyal to your country
and ultimately they're here to gain for
their own benefit yep all right Drees
says as a former information system
security manager for the Air Force I can
say that for that position you require a
top secret seci clearance to work White
House computer
security I I I I have to imagine they're
they're stripping him I mean dude he
just blabbed to a random guy he met on
the internet he didn't even know who it
was yeah imagine
J yeah it's almost funnier if they're
like okay fine you can stay but don't go
on any more dates with James o'e
yeah dreu Arrow says driving is not a
privilege Thompson V Smith 154 SE 579 11
American jurist Prudence constitutional
law etc etc the right of the citizen to
travel includes automobile thereon for
use in life and
business uh
the right to travel includes automobile
but what does that mean you're not
you're not saying that we have a a right
to drive a car are
you well on the driving test it
definitely says it's a privilege not a
right I can respect the it's a right to
be able to travel as you see fit but I
don't know that if I was buck naked in
the middle of the woods I'd have a right
to drive around in a car I suppose you
would in that sense you know
self-defense is a human right it's a
natural right it exists but uh you know
all right if that's what the law states
then then so be
it let's grab some more Super
chats Matt H says how crazy would it be
if Javier mle is a US s up to get South
Americans to fight in our
military
maybe jayd says I work in military
recruiting they're not joining not even
the DACA can join AR 61210 does not
allow it they have to be US citizens or
legal prent residents with an i 551
green card that's a really great Point
Jay do also it's illegal to cross the
border in the way they are and and it's
also illegal for Customs and Border
Patrol agents to work hand inand with
human Smugglers and NOS to bring them
and drive them to their uh to the
airport it's also illegal to have
boarding passes that say no name given
and have these people boarding planes
without going through proper security
there was also so you're right but I
understand there was also that
congressman who who floated this idea I
mean less than six months ago probably
less than three months ago saying Hey
what if we just let them join the
military and earn citizenship so this is
already a narrative that started you
know just I don't think it's off the
table I think this is ultimately aoy I
just don't trust this I think it's a
terrible idea etc
etc all right let's grab some
more April April ladderback says the
Border Convoy isn't going all the way
down to the Border but to Dripping
Springs to show support and prey guy in
charge is a retired lieutenant colonel
you should read more about it online at
take our border back very cool I really
love the idea of people going down uh
and praying and protesting peacefully
and not going in any way to interfere in
any any capacity with a board I'm glad
to hear that's what that that's what the
story actually
is here we go Exon men says Kanye pushes
Kelsey aside
yep I'm let you finish your proposal
here but she's a s working for the
Pentagon a lot of people saying like
that was the moment this country truly
started to fall that was a split I think
it was harambe honestly I think that's
what did it that was a rough time yeah
everything fell apart after
that all right where we at Ox LOM says
weird door Dash today it just felt sus
two Hispanics in very dirty clothes one
ran to Door while driver was slowly
creeping down the street with door open
didn't speak English and you don't need
a driver's license to work for door Dash
you don't it's crazy I mean I gotta be
honest that sounds efficient yeah one
guy drives keeps the car in idle you pop
the door you run up drop it off run back
jump in the car you're gone that sounds
efficient to me dude what do you mean as
long as you don't eat my food or touch
it we're good yeah true I mean say
you're here illegally then that's not
great Mark Cuban's Twitter hacked yeah
he was posting a bunch of weird stuff or
something I think he's trying so he was
retweeting a bunch of stuff about uh Sam
Hyde made a tweet about like his Jewish
name before his name so I think he was
trying to retweet it to talk about the
hate media policy on Twitter but if you
look at his timeline it's like Nick
Fuentes tweets you know whole n yards
like I think he's just retweeting it to
like prove a point about how hate speech
is out of control on Twitter I think
that's where it's going so Mark hubin
facilitates hate speech what a hypocrite
all right my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
and it's going to be a whole lot of fun
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Taylor do you want to shout anything out
uh tenant media make sure to follow them
on YouTube I believe it's watch tenant
now on all social media platforms so
that's where all my reporting ends up
and you know other content that I create
and make and uh Tim's culture War show
was now actually streamed there every
Friday I believe so yeah follow that and
then Taylor USA on Twitter that's where
you can find me it's been fun having you
here uh I'm Hannah Clair brimo I'm a
writer for cnr.com that's scanner news
you can follow all of our work on
Twitter and Instagram at timcast news
follow it immediately please if you want
to follow me personally I'm on Twitter
at hcbo and I'm on Instagram at hana. B
Brett so nice to see you perfect and
thank you uh guys if you want to follow
me I'm on Instagram and Twix at Brett
dvic on both of those platforms but go
ahead and check out pop culture crisis
we are live Monday through Friday 3 p
p.m. Eastern Standard Time we're about
to hit 98,000 subscribers so we are
going to hit the 100,000 Mark really
really soon here which we are very very
excited about it's gonna be a lot of fun
so uh check us out there Monday through
Friday at 3M popculture crisis.com right
yes we learned that last time that I did
not know that we had a website everyone
go to popculture crisis.com check out
the show if you like it hit that
subscribe button and uh yeah we were
banned off Tik Tok so that's crazy
congratulations we we always anger the
feminists don't support the Chinese
government yes and serge Serge yeah
that's a markup Pride yes I would be
proud of that uh I'm surge.com uh I
enjoyed Today's Show always good to see
you Taylor thank you for coming doing
good work out there and uh yeah let's do
the after show we'll see you all over at
timcast.net